I don't have a funny one for you today.
Well, you're fired.
(man laughing)
You have one job.
(upbeat music)
I'm not sure I'm ready, but the clock is ticking,
we're starting.
Hey, everybody, welcome to Roll On,
where the Twitter to my Instagram,
the LinkedIn to my YouTube,
the Microsoft word to my Google docs,
Mr. Adam Schick and I,
Wait, wait, why am I-
Settle in to-
Where are my Twitter, LinkedIn and Microsoft?
Because I'm the one who wrote that, that's why.
I'll take it.
Are you more LinkedIn or YouTube?
Do I watch more YouTube or LinkedIn?
No, what do you self-identify with?
Oh, self-identify?
Which platform?
Friender.
If a platform was a person, who are you?
If a platform were a person,
I am not an Excel spreadsheet, I can tell you that.
Yeah, is that a platform?
That's an app, I don't know.
All right-
Spotify.
Spotify, okay.
We are here back in the lime green chairs to banter across
an admittedly absurd long table to dissect matters,
niche trivial and vital, across the spectrum
of our whimsical curiosities today.
I've got a couple cool announcements.
We're gonna recap some behind the scenes on recent episodes,
which is a new little feature we're gonna test out.
We're gonna share as always a few highlights
from the subculture of endurance.
We're gonna impart some truths and lessons learned
from 10 years of hosting this podcast.
We're gonna recommend some high quality content
we've been enjoying.
We're gonna answer a few listener questions
and probably go off on a few random tangents along the way.
But first, how goes it fine sir?
You're typing?
Am I on?
Yeah, I was trying.
Are you typing?
We're recording right now.
The typing was supposed to happen before.
Is this thing on?
We started recording.
Oh, sorry guys.
We're off to an incredible start.
I'm still hot.
Yeah.
I'm still sweltering hot.
You know how you go for a run and you come back
and you sweat for almost as long as the run.
Now I'm sweating for three hours after every-
It's downright tropical out there.
There's a wave of humidity that is unprecedented in my,
I don't know how many years I've lived here, since 1996.
I don't ever remember...
I mean, we just endured a heat wave
that was pretty epic.
This is the last day of it, I think.
Of 110 plus every single day.
And what was unique about that was,
it didn't cool down at night usually,
but the desert here even when it's super hot during the day,
it'll still go down at night, didn't do that at all.
It was 90 degrees at one in the morning.
And then we had a little bit of rain,
and that brought upon us this humidity,
which feels we're in Hawaii or the east coast.
Very, even further south.
It's full tropical.
I was running at night, I was running.
Doesn't matter.
Yeah, it didn't matter.
I was trying different things,
but I'm not really one of those people
that complains about weather.
I don't people who complain about weather.
Are you sure about that?
Yeah, I am.
Here you go.
Here I am complaining about the weather.
When you have an opportunity to do it on a large platform,
you're gonna take advantage of that
and complain about the heat, aren't you?
'Cause that's what everyone wants to hear it.
It has been warm.
Yeah, it has.
Sorry guys, I didn't have that-
Is that all that's going on with you?
A funny intro.
What's going on with me?
No, things have been good, busy.
Working hard on some projects
I can't tell you about right now.
When is that gonna change?
That's generally the case.
I'm doing all this cool stuff and we can't talk about it.
Pretty soon.
Yeah, maybe five, six weeks
we can talk about some of it.
All right.
But so that's been good, the family's well,
no real complaints looking at,
my one complaint is that I've been trying to look-
Beyond the weather.
My second complaint,
we're trying to figure out travel stuff.
And I'm stunned at how expensive,
renting crappy condos can be in Hawaii these days.
Have you seen that?
Well, everybody's back to traveling.
Is that what it is?
So everything is at a premium now.
So now that we're coming out of this tunnel of work,
we're trying to figure out a way to fly around again.
So hopefully next year is more travel content in my life.
But otherwise good.
Been watching a lot of tennis.
Can we talk about the tennis?
We can, I didn't watch any of it.
Although I know it was fire U.S open,
but I was too busy to tap into it too deeply.
Carlos Alcaraz, Carlitos,
the youngest number one player
in the history of men's tennis.
He won the U.S open.
He's been kind of this guy that people who watch tennis
have said, this could be finally the young guy
that's as good or is on the same trajectory
as the big three, right?
We know Novak and Rafa and Roger Federer.
And all the young guys that have come up
have always hit against that glass ceiling
of those three guys, they couldn't get through 'em.
This guy Alcaraz, earlier in the year
is his third tournament he won,
he had to go through Novak and Rafa
two days in a row.
And then he won a tournament against Vera,
another highly ranked player.
And this time though,
Rafa got beat by Frances Tiafoe,
who was the best American in this tournament.
And is one of the best Americans around.
A little bit older than Alcaraz, Alcaraz in 19,
Tiafoe, I think is 24.
And they had an epic, epic five set match.
And I found it interesting because they have kind of
parallel stories in a way, Carlos Alcaraz
was raised around a tennis center.
His grandfather helped found and build,
Francis Tiafoe was raised at a tennis center,
the tennis center at college park, in Maryland,
suburban tennis.
His parents immigrated in the 90s from Sierra Leone
when it was civil war.
And they came to the DC area.
And Tiafoe's dad, Constant,
I believe is his name,
was one of the construction workers
building that tennis center.
And he worked so hard and was the best worker
that they asked him to stay on as maintenance
for the whole facility.
And so he lived there five days a week.
They lived in a back office,
and he lived with his two sons.
And Francis was seen hitting balls against the wall one day.
And these coaches found him and they basically,
within a few years, by the time he was 14 years old,
he was the number one junior in the history,
number one junior in America.
Yeah, it's such a cool story.
Yeah, and so I just was thinking about how
it's very Gladwell in, -
The polarities.
Yeah, but they both basically had the same access.
One was a little more traditional.
If your grandfather runs a tennis center,
it makes sense that you would...
The other one is kind of seems more good fortune,
but in the end that doesn't matter to the kid.
The kid's still there without all that access.
Yeah, access.
It's sort of
the Gladwell and story about,
was he the one who told the story about Bill Gates?
Exactly.
That access to that mainframe.
Yeah.
It's exactly that.
I mean, obviously you have to have the hunger
and they both did, and it was an amazing match,
it's worth seeing if you haven't seen it.
It's a long one, it's five setter.
But Carlos went through three matches,
kind of that and then got to the final
and is just a magnificent athlete.
It does feel the ushering in of a new era though.
You hope so.
but at the same time, Novak couldn't come
because he didn't get vaccinated
so he wasn't allowed in the country, and Rafa lost.
So if Novak's there does he
defend the glass ceiling.
Well, when that Tete happens,
it'll make for must watch tennis.
Yeah, but anyway, enough about
my television watching of tennis, how are you?
What's going on, what's the latest?
Oh, humidity.
Adam, I'm gonna complain about the heat.
That's on here.
No, sorry I was just distracted by all the sea monsters
on your shirt.
Yeah, this is not a good shirt for the video, right?
Video they want just plain.
What kind of-
Paisley.
Prosthesis?
Oh these?
Sea life is that?
Well, this is something I discovered in
the water's out in point doom.
Because I discovered it, I got to name it,
and this is the Richies rollies jellyfish.
It's gonna be some skull Nick and, all right.
Okay.
I'm good, I don't know what to tell you.
How's your back?
You've been exercising more.
It's not amazing,
but it's tolerable enough that I can get out there
and do some zone one and some zone two stuff
as long as I don't push it too much.
So I've been out on the bike with some regularity,
which has felt really nice.
Yeah.
You were running, right?
Doing some trails.
Like more hiking with a little bit of jogging
to test things out.
And that definitely ended up with some tightness back there.
So I'm trying to be really cautious about that,
but at least I'm getting out there and feeling good.
Yeah, I don't know.
Everything's good man.
My older boys and their band, Blood Ocean,
they going out on tour right now.
They're going up and down the west coast.
Which is really fun to see them finally take their music
on the road and play these little venues and,
That's cool,
Visit these cities and do the whole,
jam into a van thing.
Phenomena.
It's pretty cool.
So I'm getting some cool reports from the road.
Shout out to friend of the pod and friend in real life,
Jesse Thomas and Lauren Fleshman who
opened up their guest house to my boys
and their band mates when they played in Ben
the other night, which was really cool.
So they played in Portland last night.
They're going up to Seattle.
They're gonna be in San Louis Obispo.
I've shared their tour schedule, maybe I'll share it again.
I love what you posted and they sound fabulous.
Yeah, they're doing good.
So are that's been cool watching that.
Have there been a group yet?
Is there one groupie?
I don't know.
They don't tell you?
I've been getting reports on the road,
the slow disasters and the highlights and the low,
they play a show, nobody shows up.
Or, there was the venue in San Francisco
that basically wasn't gonna pay them
and all that kind of stuff.
But that's good, that's the way it's supposed to be.
They have that real life experience.
You gotta go through it.
Did they destroy Jesse and Lauren's home
, real rock stars.
Hopefully not.
Like real rock stars.
So a braider party back there
and just paint the walls.
Hopefully not.
Okay, good.
I cautioned them and explain to them
that they had to acquit themselves as gentlemen.
Oh, gentlemen rockers.
They seem gentlemen rockers.
They are, they're very solid young men.
Super proud of them.
Couple announcements before we get into it.
The first thing is, well, I should say that,
this podcast is slowly moving away from being a free diving
podcast to an anvil free promotional fans.
Speaking of less into rockers (laughs).
So for all of you that caught the last Roll On,
you'll remember the story that I shared about my friend,
Sasha Gervasi, and the improbable story
behind his documentary Anvil, story of Anvil.
One of the greatest rock docs of all time,
which is being rereleased next week in 200 theaters
across the United States, 13 years after its initial run.
So it's a really cool thing.
We're recording this on Monday, but two days from now and
before this podcast will actually air September 13,
the movie is premiering in New York city,
which will be last night.
If you're listening to this podcast right after a post
at the Angelica.
And it's an event that was hosted by Sasha and Peter Diage,
who stared in Sasha's HBO movie, "My dinner with Ivey."
That's cool.
So you guys missed that, but I wanted to let you know.
He also starred in something called "Game of Thrones."
He did, yeah.
Yeah, but I'm trying to connect
why Peter would be, co-hosting Sasha
Mayor in New York,
because they work together in any event, I get you.
But for all of you, Los Angelinos, Los Galinos,
or for anybody contemplating a track to the city of angels
allow me to entice you because Anvil will be premiering
the newly restored and mastered print in Los Angeles
on September 23rd at the Saban theater.
And I wanted to offer up to you guys,
the audience, two free pairs of tickets for the screening,
which will include a not to be forgotten,
I promise you, live Anvil rock show.
Like you've never seen anything these guys rocking out.
After the screening that's gonna happen.
And that's gonna be hosted by friend of the pod
and real life friends, Stevo,
who I believe is gonna be doing a Q&A
with Sasha and her band.
And there's gonna be some other yet to be disclosed,
super special guests that I'm forbidden from mentioning
at this moment.
So that's pretty, pretty cool.
I mean, Sasha wanted me to help,
kind of open it up to you guys.
So to enter to win these tickets,
you can send an email to giveawayrichroll.com.
Please send that in before September 18th,
and put the word Anvil in the subject line,
and we'll select the winners at random on September 19th.
In the meantime,
if you wanna just buy tickets to that event,
you can do that as well.
It's just Anvil, I think it's Anvil the Band.
Oh, anvilthefilm.com.
These special guests are these potential
other musicians that might share the stage.
Yeah, maybe.
All right.
Maybe.
Yeah, anvilthefilm.com.
So you could just buy tickets
and go to this premier screening, I'm gonna be there.
We're probably gonna do a meet and greet.
It's gonna be super fun.
Saban Theater, I never knew it was Saban.
I would thought it was Steve Saban.
Saban, no, I think it's Saban.
Yeah, I think you're right.
For sure.
How are you in Angelino and you don't know that.
I missed that.
Anyway, you missed the memo on that.
The second announcement I wanna make is that,
some of you may, remember long time listeners
will remember that, towards the end of last year
we released a special episode called Profits Walk Among Us
stories from our listeners,
which was an entire episode that was devoted to sharing
voice messages sent in by all of you guys.
It was one of our most unique and impactful episodes
to date, really proud of that.
It was just a beautiful thing,
putting that together and sharing it with everyone,
just a total joy to produce.
If you haven't heard it,
I recommend adding it to your queue immediately.
And it was so meaningful to us and everyone who listened
and reached out that we're gonna do it again.
So if you're willing to participate,
please consider sharing with me
your personal journey of transformation,
how the podcast and it's many guests have inspired you,
and maybe some things about what you've learned,
you've practiced, you've implemented or shared
with others along the way.
And in other words,
how has the show served you in your life?
How has it benefited you, how has it orientated you,
inspired you to reframe your vision of family, of work,
your sense of self.
And we're gonna take those messages and compile a portion
of the submissions into the next edition of this
listener focused format.
So if you're keen to participate,
you can leave your story on a special voicemail
that we've set up, so call 805-421-0057.
And we look forward to hearing from you.
Yeah, and if I've helped you in any way, don't hold back,
put it all out there.
We need to hear about it.
I want messages all about Adam.
I think that would be great.
If I've done anything for you at all,
even if it's negative, I want to hear about it.
Put it on the voicemail.
Are you sure about that?
All right, cool.
Yeah, again, 805-421-0057
and we'll put that voicemail number
in the show notes as well.
That sounds cool, can't wait for that one.
Let's do this thing where we kind of recap
some of the most recent episodes-
What should we call it?
I don't know.
Well, maybe they leave that on the voice note too.
The recaper?
That's already Bill Simmons thing.
He has a recap?
Well, he has the rewatchables.
Right.
This wouldn't be the rewatchable, the re-listen.
I don't know, the behind the scenes.
I don't know.
Well, let's not debate that now.
In other words-
This is not the time to work-
What I wanna do is,
there are podcasts out there that kind of recap the episode
that you've just heard by sharing a little
behind the scenes thoughts.
And they generally do that in the intros or the outros
of the respective episodes.
We don't do that or have not done that historically.
But my sense, my spy sense is that
maybe some of you out there might enjoy a little bit
of storytelling around some of the guests.
So we thought that we would do that here
and see how it goes.
So since we last sat down, Adam,
well, there's been three episodes.
Ken Rideout episode, Gabor Mate,
and the one that just went up today, Max Fisher.
I don't know, we can start with Ken Rideout,
although you haven't listened to that one.
You don't actually listen to the show, do you?
Wait, what (laughs)?
This has changed.
I don't know how this is gonna go.
I do listen to the show.
I know you do.
But-
Not every-
Your problem with me is I don't commute.
And so my podcast listening has to be very elitist.
I don't commute.
And they say, you're not supposed to listen to podcast
in front of young children, infants and toddlers.
Do they say that?
No, I didn't know that.
Why is that?
Because you're distracted from your full attention.
It's just, that's not a great way for language,
for them to pick up language.
And it's disassociated talking and it's not -
Oh, that's interesting, I didn't know that.
Well, that's the stuff when you read
these early childhood development kind of materials,
that's one thing that has come out, but that's-
Convenient excuse.
That's not a great excuse.
But Ken Rideout I'm very familiar with,
because I think we talked about him before,
when Fiedman's story came up and you were talking about
that you wanted to get him on.
So I am familiar with his story,
he was a corrections officer and hit wall street
and went nuts, and then after that had kind of
an addiction issue, right?
That kind of almost submarined his entire life.
And now is the fastest marathoner over 50.
Yeah, it's a crazy story.
Yeah, I mean, everything that he overcame
to be the person that he is, is super inspiring.
And I think his story kind of hits on the real sweet spot
of this podcast, which are these personal stories
of transformation, overcoming obstacles and odds to,
accomplish something lauditory.
And his is very powerful as his
sort of command of telling the story too.
And he's got this totally nuts back story,
what he overcame as immense.
And it was funny,
I was sort of intimidated to meet him.
'Cause he's a super, at least,
what I was sort of projecting onto him was that
he would be super alpha and difficult to...
Yeah, and he wasn't that at all.
He was a really sweet guy and that episode really connected
and his stuff blew up as a result.
And he was on the receiving end of a lot of,
attention as a result.
That's awesome.
And he was so grateful and he was so
almost emotional in his kind of overwhelm with,
the response to that, which was really sweet.
And it just made me realize,
there's lots of guys out there with tough guy exteriors.
And a lot of them don't have what Ken has,
which is this huge heart.
Like, to me, that's the differentiator.
Like he really is a sensitive soul who cares deeply
about other people and in a way that,
not that other people don't do that,
but there's a way that he wears it on his sleeve.
Right, he's accessible.
Yeah, he's very vulnerable with his emotions
around that, which you don't often find
with guys that are,
kind of tough guys or grew up in tough circumstances.
There was one cool story that we didn't get to
in the podcast that maybe I can share now.
Which was that when Ken was a corrections officer,
I guess I'm not supposed to call it a prison guard.
Although I think that's the term he used,
but I got in trouble 'cause I prison guard,
and corrections officer is the correct.
I did a story on prison reform once.
Oh, you did?
And I had a copy editor look at it,
and the copy editor inserted typos,
but tried to tell me not to use the term prisoner.
And so basically he wanted to call prisoners,
incarcerated persons.
And so the copy editor changed all prisoner references,
incarcerated persons,
that created typos and really bad sentences.
And so I had to have a negotiation to call them inmate.
How long ago was that?
It would be 2017.
Well, I think 2018-
You can't can't use the word prisoner anymore.
Prisoner you can't use,
even though they're residents of a prison,
you can't use prisoner.
Even though I wasn't suggesting they belonged in prison,
I was saying they are prisoners.
But you can call it a prison.
That's okay.
That's my point.
Incarcerated person facility.
I don't know, I didn't get the memo this week.
There should be a white paper
that comes out every Monday.
Like these are the words that are allowed.
Oh, these words are back?
Okay, I can use these words again, but these words are out.
Yeah.
So corrections officer.
Corrections officer.
But when he was a corrections officer,
he actually worked with Mickey Ward.
Who was also a corrections officer?
I guess so, yeah.
And if that name sounds familiar,
it might be because he was the boxer who was played by
Mark Walberg in the movie, "The Fighter,"
it's Christian Bale
who played Mickey's half brother, Dicky Eland.
That movie being directed by David O. Russell,
which was incredible film.
Great movie.
I think it's probably fair to say that that movie was
an accurate depiction of the type of environment in which,
Ken grew up in.
He grew up south Boston.
Yeah, I think, yeah.
Yeah, I don't know exactly the neighborhood in Boston.
But basically pretty chaotic and rough and tumble.
And I just think,
I'm so glad that people enjoyed listening to him
and hearing his story.
To me, he's an example of a healthy alpha male,
a solid role model for young men and older men too.
Or maybe all people, whether we're in corrections or not.
All people,
but you'll have to be a male.
That's true.
It's cool, man.
And I love stories that.
Yeah, yeah, any story.
And I love ...
What people ask me all the time,
who's your favorite guest?
Da, da, da, da.
And I can't say there is a favorite guest,
but I think I do have a sweet spot for...
You're not a guest, you're a cohost.
Okay, right.
Right.
You being all indignant over there.
It's these stories of personal transformation
I think that are kind of the-
The bread and butter.
The bread and vegan butter.
Well it's funny that these three
that we're gonna talk about are all three
of the kind of pillars
that you've always brought out,
which are at least kind of under reported amazing stories
of transformation that are instantly inspiring
and can inspire transformation in others.
Doctors that kind of look at the medical world
with a more critical eye and have a different take
necessarily than the mainstream medical mind.
And then the book that we're gonna talk about at the end,
you're sitting down with an author
and going full Terry Gross.
I mean, I think that's what makes the show so special
is that you go to these different worlds.
It's the curiosity model.
Well, this is why you're my cohost.
'Cause you butter my bread.
I encapsulate and then you serve that softball that.
Make me look better than I am, but I appreciate that.
Hey, I mean it.
Dr. Gabor Mate, another episode you haven't listened to.
Didn't get to that one.
(both laughing)
It's in the key.
In fairness,
we only came up with this segment yesterday.
So I didn't give you a lot of heads up or time.
No, but-
Maybe going forward, we'll figure that out.
I did watch some of Gabor Mate's ritual content
on the-
The reels.
On the slot slot machine in my Palm.
I did watch that, and very interesting.
I always find especially now, 'cause it's,
for years I didn't have health insurance.
I don't know if you can believe that but,
I couldn't afford health insurance.
Nor could I.
For years.
And I would pay out of pocket for things acupuncture
and alternative health stuff,
because I actually didn't really want to go
to the medical doctor.
And I think in the last years for many reasons,
I think starting with April being pregnant
and finally having health insurance, that's one part of it.
You know, after Obamacare passed,
I was able to get health insurance and moving forward,
I kind of still, I tapped into it,
but I still kind of stayed a little bit halfway.
And I think there had been a time in my life
where I would fully resonate with everything he said.
And this time I would watched the content and
he referenced drugs used for Ms and rheumatoid arthritis.
And it's very interesting because
I actually have a story about rheumatoid arthritis.
A friend of mine had rheumatoid arthritis
and turned down all the drugs
and he decided he didn't believe in that
because the doctors were basically saying, you're incurable.
You're gonna have to take these drugs the rest of your life
and won't help you that much.
So in that sense,
that's where I believe Dr. Mate is coming from,
is that that's the only thing people can recommend for you.
And it doesn't necessarily help you.
In fact, maybe it does hurt you or shorten your lifespan.
He decided to look for a nutritional change,
got rid of all grains and still kind of went through
the process but in the meantime,
lost all the connective tissue cartilage in his hands.
He went through incredible pain.
Like it's a miracle he's survived.
Two years later he's come out of it.
He's growing that cartilage back.
He's not eating grains, that's what really did it.
He figured his own way out, but it was hell.
And so, that's the one thing his recommendations,
I'm not saying they're false,
I'm saying there is a price to be paid.
Yeah, I mean, I think that clip
really triggered certain people.
And part of that is my fault.
It is taken a bit out of context,
but he is pushing the boundaries of,
what we're kind of accustomed to hearing
when it comes to how we treat medical conditions.
And that specific reel,
he basically is saying, listen,
as you said, there are,
in certain cases with certain conditions,
the medical prognosis and the prescriptions
that are part and parcel of that,
are not necessarily the solution.
And there is an opportunity to go beyond that
and to look deeper
to probe into somebody's emotional psyche.
Like in the case of your friend,
he discovered a nutritional solution
that ultimately put him on a better path.
Dr. Mate is suggesting an emotional exploration.
Which is even another level.
That's hard,
especially if you're somebody who suffers
or you have a loved one who suffers,
who's going through hell and has tried all sorts of things
or really has, found a way
to live well on these medications.
That's a difficult thing to hear.
And I'm compassionate towards that.
I don't think what he's saying is that in all cases,
this is the solution,
but perhaps instead there is something to be learned,
gleaned or experienced
by opening your aperture and trying to,
delve into what's going on with you emotionally
as a path towards some version of healing.
Whether in partnership or not with traditional,
Western medical approaches to whatever ails you.
It's something that's worth exploring and considering.
And given, he's not some wackadoodle guys
who's coming outta nowhere.
This guy's been treating people forever.
And his thesis emerged out of his work with thousands of,
basically low bottom addicts in Vancouver,
and realizing the relationship between
unhealed childhood trauma and drug addiction later in life.
And this recent book that he just came out with,
"The Myth of Normal" is really about extrapolating
upon that thesis to say, at the root of many diseases,
lies things unhealed trauma or emotional distress
that is compartmentalized and not actually healed.
And if we can go in and heal that,
what are the downstream ramifications of that on health
and he would say that they're profound.
And that we need to start paying attention to that.
And I think there's there,
it's a challenging thesis and
at times, I feel I challenged him.
He challenged me.
This is something that happened in our first podcast
conversation as well,
because I'm so indoctrinated into 12 step,
I tend to view addiction and recovery through that lens
and that lens specifically.
And he's challenging me to broaden that aperture.
And, see a path to healing
that's a little bit more expansive and that
I can bristle at that or I can take that and say,
well, maybe there's something for me to learn here.
Right.
Anyway, I think that that's another episode
that is doing really well.
And I think he's helped a lot of people
and is a really important voice.
He's got a great face, wouldn't you say?
Incredible face.
Yeah.
Best face.
I think he wins best face of all these three guys.
He has an unbelievable, unmistakable face.
Before we get to these,
well, I'll ask you this at the end.
I wanted to ask you kind of a nuts and bolts question
about the podcast, but I'll ask you at the end.
But yeah, great face, great voice.
And yeah, I'm not suggesting that
any of his conclusions are wrong.
I'm just suggesting that
when you venture off the path to try some other methodology,
whether it's emotional or nutritional or whatever,
there often is a price to be paid in pain.
And that's okay if you can handle that.
But I just think that that's important to also say.
Like it sounds a better fix.
It's not an instant fix or an easy fix either.
None of these things are instant or easy.
Of course not.
But in the-
I'm not saying he's saying that,
I'm just trying to clarify.
Yeah, I understand what you're saying.
I also think that there's some additional connective tissue
between Gabor's message and Ken Rideout's message,
and what we're about to talk about, Max Fisher's message,
in that many of our larger social problems
are being driven by men,
a lot of young men who are disenfranchised,
lacking means lacking opportunity.
Who many of which I suspect are managing wounds and trauma
without any help, without any direction,
without any resources, without any strong,
healthy male role models,
all of which make them vulnerable to
less than stellar online influence,
which manifests, metastasizes,
into untoward behavior in the real world.
This is a big part of what Max Fisher talks about.
Max Fisher?
I know we're gonna talk about that.
And why I think people Ken Rideout are important
because they're an opposite to that in a healthy way.
So in the context of what Max is talking about,
I mean, first of all, to segue into him in elegantly,
I know one thing you wanted to talk about.
The name Max Fisher?
His name is Max Fisher.
His name is Max Fisher, which is,
one of the great characters in recent film history.
Wouldn't you say?
I mean, indelible, right?
Timeless.
Explain for people that might not know-
Max Fisher was the character played in "Rushmore"
by Jason Schwartzman, it's Wes Anderson's second film.
It's arguably, you could argue it's his best film.
I don't know if you would.
I think it's one of the top five, it's in my top five.
It's definitely in the top five.
I don't know that it's his best though.
But it was the one that really
bottle rocket was good, but this was another level.
And Bill Murray kind of,
I don't know if it's accurate to say rebooted Bill Murray,
but maybe it did.
Yeah, I think it did.
And so it's an incredible movie about
a high school senior.
Toronto.
Yeah, who was this wacky high schooler.
It's amazing.
If you haven't seen "Rushmore," please stream "Rushmore."
It's unbelievable.
Do it for Max Fisher.
Do it for Max, Max Fisher.
So this one just dropped today.
You listened to a little bit of it.
The early response right outta the gate
has been pretty voluminous.
Fantastic.
I think this episode is gonna do really well.
I think it's a really important conversation.
And it's something that we can all relate to
as creatures who live to some extent
by and through the internet.
And the vicissitudes of the social media platforms
and the algorithms that make choices about what we see
and what we don't.
Yeah, it hooked me right off the bat.
I have not read the book.
What's the title?
"The Chaos Machine."
"Chaos Machine,"
yet another kind of take on how social media
is twisting society basically.
And this one has a much more global overview
and you can encapsulate it better than I can, but,
he's a foreign...
What was it?
He's a-
Foreign affairs.
Yeah, foreign affairs correspondent.
Like investigative reporter, Pulitzer prize finalist.
Yeah, and he's not the tech reporter
that you'd think would normally cover this.
You say that, right off the bat.
Yeah, I mean, that's not his beat.
He came into it through the work that he was doing overseas
when he was seeing the kind of ramifications
of what social media was doing in the developing world.
Yeah, and how it was fueling,
the Rohingya genocide and Myenmar and how
she covered for the New York times and then fueling
some rampages of Hindus, destroying Muslims homes in India,
and those riots in 2012,
which he didn't recognize the social media component there.
And he kind of feels ashamed of that now,
which he talks about with you.
So that is really interesting.
I've covered Mermar a lot.
So that really peaked my interest as well.
And then, talking about Zuckerberg's quote,
did you have that quote or was it he that had the quote?
What's the quote?
About rewiring society, society is a math
or is a problem?
Oh, I think, well, it was Zuckerberg who said that,
yeah, that basically,
I can't remember the exact quote,
but it's something along the lines of,
humanity is an engineering problem.
Yeah, humanity is an engineering problem.
And so the arrogance and kind of,
I guess, glee that kind of is with arrogance glee
and excellence, that kind of came together
to create what we are now kind of all armed with,
which is a slot machine.
Basically, he says so eloquently, in our pockets.
All that, it's all intentional.
It's basically, we're all dopamine addicts.
He wants you to-
It's intentional on the front end
but it is unpredictable on the back end.
Because I don't think anybody could have foreseen.
No.
What would transpire as a result of their creation.
And now everyone's in, I don't know if it's damage control,
but they are trying to figure out how to rectify
this thing that clearly is driving us apart from each other,
creating social division and ultimately,
wreaking untold havoc.
Yeah, I mean, and arrogance, I think is part of that.
And I don't know.
I mean, I find it really compelling.
I know you're really into the book.
What else should we do?
I mean, the way that I think of the book is,
if you watch that documentary, "The Social Dilemma."
This is the equivalent of a
semester long college course on that subject matter
where each thing that comes up in the social dilemma
is just probed a little bit more deeply.
And it does have a global focus-
Which I love beyond.
The parameters of the United States.
And I think, another important takeaway is that
it's less about vilifying the Zuckerbergs of the world,
and more about understanding the inherent incentives
of the systems and the platforms themselves
that are built to take maximum advantage
of the systems.
I mean, basically most of them are there to sell ads
and they're there to command your attention
so they can serve up as many ads as possible.
And with those built in incentives,
you're creating platforms that ultimately,
are so addictive that it's almost impossible for
the well-intentioned human being
to have a healthy relationship with them.
It's interesting, right off the bat,
you guys start talking about the Rohingya Myanmar issue,
which was a Facebook issue and how the UN has actually said
that Facebook exacerbated what ended up being
kind of a series of pogroms that destroyed settlements,
and basically killed and murdered and maimed and raped,
Rohingya people from the majority Burman population
was involved in that, some of them was the military.
The military has been doing that to ethnic groups
around Myanmar, I've covered that several times.
But in this case, it wasn't just the military,
it was also regular people kind of going in similar to
what happened in India.
And I'm not suggesting that,
that obviously happens, the thing is
he also talks about how much of this is human nature.
Is this human nature mixed with
kind of this new tech problem.
And I think that's interesting because-
He acknowledges the human nature component of it as being,
a huge aspect of these problems,
as you know and have pointed out,
existed prior to social media.
Yeah, yeah.
India, there's been mobs destroying Muslim
homes and settlements and slums in India for,
generations, there's been in Indonesia,
there was Muslim mobs that went and killed
and destroyed, the whole ethnic Chinese neighborhoods
in Jakarta and other parts of Java
and across Indonesia, this stuff has happened.
Korea town was destroyed during the riots.
And that was intentional, that it was Korea town.
And so these things have happened before social media,
but now social media is kind of exacerbating it.
And it's funny 'cause you point out quite rightly that
what we were talking about in Myanmar, in India
and other places is the polar opposite
of the Arab spring, where all these same platforms
were exuberant about their possibilities
to really change the world for the better.
And then this is the dark aftermath.
Which is the real dragon that they built.
So that was interesting.
Yeah.
Listen, it's a fascinating and far reaching problem.
I do believe,
I'm not a fan of villainizing,
the execs and making them the ultimate bad guys here.
Like, I do feel, I don't know, maybe there's-
Are you defending the man right now?
No, I feel as individuals,
there is an understanding that there's a problem
that needs to be dealt with.
And I think that they're probably grappling
with how to solve a problem that
structurally just feels impossible to solve.
When you have a structure, a business plan,
that is a for profit enterprise,
short of turning off the platform,
how do you fix this,
content moderation with human beings
or through some kind of artificial intelligence
is never gonna hit the mark.
It's always gonna be too much or too little.
It's gonna call people off it.
Air freshener outside of toxic waste dumpers.
And whoever's trying to propagate
who's not on a bender to propagate some kind of campaign,
whether well-intentioned or not,
is always gonna have the advantage in terms of
figuring out an end run around
whatever moderation is going on.
So it's almost
a SIS fian task of trying to solve it.
Like, I don't know how it can be solved,
but ultimately in the meantime,
it's massively problematic.
Oh, a hundred percent.
Do you feel conflicted in the fact that,
you're on Instagram today with these tiles,
basically talking about these same problems,
but by doing that, it's kind of,
it's we talked about last time,
which is the medium is the message.
It's almost,
and I think I referenced last time this book for arguments,
for the elimination of television,
it's about, no matter what you put on the television,
this was the argument.
Like the way the television works is,
we are not seeing the picture we're seeing pixels.
And the pictures actually being put together in our brain
different than film which is light,
well, suppose back in the day was light through film.
And so it was an image on film,
wasn't being built in our brains,
but because the way television works,
it's being built in your brain.
That was one of the arguments
for the elimination of television, this old book
that is a great book, but I'm sure out of print now.
This reminds me of that kind of book.
It's, these are the arguments for why the internet
and social media should not exist probably.
Right, but I'm a product of the internet.
Like I make a living as...
If the internet didn't exist, if social media didn't exist,
I would not be able to do this thing right now.
And I try to leverage the pipes for good.
But the truth of the matter
is that I'm completely dependent upon these platforms
in order to do this thing that we're doing right now.
So it's complicated, right?
Like, yes, I'm on Instagram, I'm on Twitter.
I share clips from the podcast.
Like I try not to allow it to consume me,
and really use it as a creator.
Like I'm using it as a place to broadcast
the work that I'm doing as opposed to
a place for consumption.
And I plead guilty to being a consumer of it as well.
To me, that's where my work needs to focus,
my personal work, I mean, in terms of,
what are my habits around my social media usage?
Not as a broadcaster, but as a consumer.
But I think if you can reframe the relationship
into one of productivity and creativity
to use it to create rather than to consume,
then it can be unbelievably powerful.
Like I owe my entire career to the internet.
So it's, far be it from,
so what am I gonna do?
Like cast stones and shoot arrows at this thing
that has given me an unbelievable living.
If I could be so bold to try to put a positive message
out in the world and impact people in a meaningful way.
So, how do you reckon with those polarities?
I don't think you do.
I mean, you're someone as well.
Same, same.
I was a guidebook author and a freelance journalist
primarily, and those were great days.
But also all my content always went on the internet
from way back when,
and now I'm on this show and I've had the good fortune
to work with David whose book became a hit on Amazon
as purely without Amazon, there'd be no,
can't hurt me in this particular incarnation.
It would be a different type of a thing
through more of a publisher.
But even publishers, it's not just you,
it's these days, major publishers,
they wanna know how many followers you have.
Like everything, they have rewired.
The point is they have rewired sites,
certainly have rewired media, and now it matters.
Like how many followers a journalist has, it matters.
And I don't know how many Max has, but a lot.
There's a lot of people that do very well in journalism
because they have a lot of followers.
So they're playing that social-
We can argue about whether that's a good or a bad thing,
but it is true.
It's true.
Like that is the reality in which we live.
And when it comes to YouTube, I love YouTube,
I love that YouTube exists and we get to make these videos
and we put them out there and share them with people
and people enjoy them.
Like that is a net positive in my life.
But we have to recognize that there are problems with it
as well, that need to be solved
and hopefully they can be solved.
I don't know how to solve them.
We're feeding the chaos machine either way,
I think is the medium is the message,
kind of argument would be,
I'm not saying I'm not making the argument
or judging anything 'cause I'm doing the same stuff,
but the argument would be the...
Anytime you feed the chaos machine,
you're helping the chaos machine.
Even if it's good stuff.
Because you are the product.
And one of the most powerful things that has stuck with me
in that conversation with Max was,
this idea that we all think on some level
that we're exempt from that manipulation,
, oh, all these people are being manipulated
and they're going down rabbit holes.
But, not me.
I'm witnessing all of this, but I'm-
Those idiots.
Yeah, yeah.
And he's saying nobody is immune from this.
And that is a very common, reaction.
Like we all think that we're too smart for that.
And yet subtly incrementally,
we're all being lured in one direction or another,
as a result of these tectonic tech plates.
He's clearly extremely smart, but also humble,
which I d.
I mean, I just think it's a great podcast.
Like I can't wait to finish the rest of it.
I think it's interesting though, when it comes down to it,
maybe we should all unplug and just go do things
that have no productivity involved at all.
Like, just go, maybe I should just spend most of my day
under water, can I get paid to just stay under water?
Follow your bliss, follow your passion out.
Maybe that's why Killian is the greatest-
The universe will conspire to support you.
Maybe that's why Killian's the greatest endurance
or ultra runner of all time.
He does what he wants to do.
All he wants to do is just run on a trail.
He doesn't wanna look at all that shit.
No.
And look what it did for him.
Hundreds of thousands of followers on social media.
(laughs) Yeah, that's his accomplishment to you?
Come on.
All right, let's take a quick break
and we'll be back with an endurance sports check in.
Prophets walk among us,
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever that our world
is populated by scores of beautiful and brilliant people,
who have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know, who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better for the experience
of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down
the most compelling prophets on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast,
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book,
"Voicing Change" volume two.
More than mere words on paper,
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration and timeless wisdom that transpires each week
on the Ritual podcast.
The first edition of "Voicing Change" was a beautifully
rendered book worthy of display on any coffee table,
and volume two follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication, replete with interview excerpts,
essays, and stunning photography,
making for an exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets,
and physically interact with the life changing ideas
contained with them.
"Voicing Change" volume two available now
while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
All right, so during the break,
Adam had to check to see how many
Instagram followers Gil Jordanne has.
1.3 Million.
Good for him.
I undersold him.
Yeah.
Just running on mountains, doing his thing.
Exactly.
Well that brings us to-
Even he's feeding the machine.
He is, right?
Not his fault.
We all are.
We're all complicit.
At this point it's not new news,
but Killian firmly established himself as the all time GOAT
by winning UTMB.
Jim Walmsley gave him a run for his money,
really went after it, but ended up third.
Killian took home gold in that race.
And we don't need to recap the whole race
'cause it was couple weeks ago at this point.
But I thought what was interesting was-
A hundred mile race, right?
Yes, yeah.
UTMB the most prestigious mountain race.
Was this article about
his UTMB training and race data.
A lot of this data was made public and there was an article
in Trail Runner magazine,
kind of analyzing it and briefly synopsizing some
interesting takeaways.
So from that, which I think is instructive,
they saw, and this is just what he kind of shared publicly,
maybe he's doing more training beyond
what was in his Strava and kind of his chorus data
from his GPS watch, but he logged 1200 hours of training
annual, over the year, 1200 hours.
88% of that training was at lower intensity
and included a ton of cross training.
And most instructive was just the incredible amount of
zone one and zone two training.
So 56.9% of his training was in zone one,
20.2% in zone two.
At the highest end zone five only 3.8% of his training,
which I thought was super interesting.
We'll link up this article in the show notes,
but it kind of goes through zone by zone, his approach.
And I think if you're somebody who thinks that
marathon runners and ultra runners log a bunch of junk miles
and let's just get rid of the junk miles.
I think Killian is powerful proof that
those are not junk miles.
Like he's building this just implacable foundation,
this base that makes him bulletproof and very resilient
as a runner.
So anyway, I thought that was really cool.
Super interesting, zone one.
I can't pack a bag in zone one.
You can't, you don't have...
See, for Killian to run in his zone one,
which is walking for a normal human being,
he could probably run
seven minute miles in his zone one.
You think in zone one?
Because he's so efficient.
On flat ground, seven minute miles zone one.
And he's been building this space for so long, right?
His zone one pace is,
I'd be very interested to know what his zone one pace is.
Yeah, I'd be interested too.
Anyway, speaking of long distance running,
the 3,100 self transcendence run is underway.
I think they're on day nine at this point.
Longtime listeners will remember Sonja Robal,
who was on the podcast back in 2018.
That was episode 389.
He is a runner and a filmmaker.
He made a documentary called "3,100 Run and Become,"
which is all about this race.
Following some of the participants.
Essentially, you know what this race is, don't you?
No.
Oh, I talked about it with Camille Heron,
'cause she's interested in doing it.
But it's a 3,100 mile running race,
where you basically run around this city block in Queens.
That's, I don't know, a half mile long.
They open up the course in the morning
and they close it at night.
So it's not, no sleep, you sleep at night
and you show up in the morning
and you run as much as you can
until they close the course.
And you have to complete the 3,100 miles in 52 days or less.
So basically you have to run an average of 59.6 miles a day.
The 2019 winner did it in 47 days.
And this is just one of the most insane races
in existence.
A crazy maker.
Yeah.
And the people that compete in it, interestingly,
I mean, you should watch Sanjay's documentary,
we'll link it up in the show notes.
You can get it on Amazon Prime.
This guy, I think he's the same guy who won in 2019,
his name is Ashprihanal Aalto.
He was 48 years old in 2019, I think he's 51 now.
I think he's a postal worker in Finland or Denmark.
I'd say-
I think you'd say that's his route.
No, no, no.
Like a lot of these competitors,
they're not professional athletes.
And they look sort of lay people,
they don't look racehorses.
Interesting.
And it's just,
the prize goes to the tortoise in this thing.
It's the guy or woman who can keep moving
the longest, it's this war of attrition.
It's kind of an unbelievable.
Crazy.
The goal is to transcend the self.
Well, yeah, it was created by Sri Chinmoy,
who's sort of this guru figure.
From that part of New York city who,
part of the kind of spiritual philosophy
is that you can achieve self transcendence
through endurance, right.
Sort of -
The marathon monks.
The marathon monks,
it's a similar kind of thing.
And so this race was born out of that.
Anyway, you can also follow Sanjay on Instagram.
He's been updating people through his stories.
He's @Mr. Sanjay R.
M-R, Sanjay R, on Instagram.
Amazing.
Before we get into the water stuff,
can we talk about Tony Riddle's upcoming room?
Yeah, please.
September 15th.
He is gonna be running Britain's longest trail,
the Southwest coastal path, it's a thousand kilometers.
He's gonna be doing it in 10 days
to beat the current record, so he is going for an FKT.
So that's a hundred kilometers a day
for 10 consecutive days.
And the elevation is equivalent to scaling
Mount Everest four times.
So what is that?
A hundred thousand plus feet of elevation gain?
And so he's doing that, starts September 15th.
He's gonna be posting about it on the Natural Life Stylist.
So that's a place to see it on Instagram,
and he's raising money.
He's raising money for the Southwest coast paths.
I guess they have a restoration fund.
And also a documentary highlighting Brazil's
next indigenous Congresswoman.
So he's his main
causes are the environment and indigenous rights,
indigenous people.
So he's got three causes that he's raising money for.
So if you are feeling it,
go over to his Instagram and you can read
a little bit more about it and then,
kick in some money or just watch the show.
Do we have links for those nonprofits
that we can put in the show notes?
Where's our link guy?
I don't know, you're our link guy.
Okay, I'll find him.
I'll give you your link.
When I was in London I did a podcast with Tony.
Oh, you did?
We talked all about his preparation for this challenge.
Just with the,
postproduction schedule and all the guests that we've had,
unfortunately, that episode's not going up
in advance of this challenge.
So when it does go up,
bear in mind that it was recorded prior to that.
In the meantime, if you want to get down with Tony,
you can listen to the first podcast that we did,
I don't know what number it was.
I love that one.
Search Google for that.
Where he got you barefoot running?
He did, and we made a little video
where he took me through some drills and things that.
Which is fun to watch.
And he has a documentary out
about his three peaks challenge,
which is called one man, two feet, three peaks.
I think it's an hour long or something that.
It's a pretty good watch.
And it gives you some good context
for who this guy is and how remarkable he is.
He is a remarkable human being.
Running, and his vivo bare foot,
and climbing these peaks barefoot.
Family man.
Wild, no furniture in his house.
No, family, man.
Lot of squatting, a lot of natural movements.
They sit on the floor, they sleep on these pads, right?
Yeah, but they don't have chairs.
And he's a beautiful, wonderful guy.
Just love that guy to death, so cool.
A transcendence.
Should we talk about this
a hundred mile offshore challenge?
Is it even a challenge?
No, I mean-
I remember when this came up.
Did you post it?
I wonder if I saw it on your Twitter
or on one of my other many daily forays into social media.
This came up and was suddenly everywhere.
So this rapper, (laughs).
Young Thug.
Young Thug posted from jail, I guess.
So his roommate is that fellow,
a fellow who was incarcerated person, his roommate.
What do you mean his roommate?
I'm talking with my roommate.
And we're wondering if you had...
When I read that tweet, I didn't realize it was Young Thug.
I thought it was just some dude talking to his roommate.
I did too,
because we're old men and we don't know what's going on.
But Young Thug said, "I'm talking with my roommate..."
We tweeted this, "I'm talking with my roommate.
"And we're wondering if you could swim a hundred miles
"from the middle of the ocean,
"back to shore, Michael Phelps."
And Michael Phelps retweeted it
and said, "Yeah, I think I could make it."
And this kind of exploded the internet for a minute.
Especially in the open water circles.
Like they're, please can Michael Phelps
bring some star power to our sports?
So CBS Sports ends up writing an article about this,
taking it seriously.
Like, could he actually do this?
What would it take and talks about who Young Thug is
and all the -
And he was in jail at the time?
Reportedly been charged with a wide ranging Rico case.
What's Rico?
And is waiting trial, racketeering.
So I don't know anything about that part of the whole deal.
You're not endorsing his Rico case.
What do you think, could Michael Phelps do this?
Well, I think he could,
I think, people have done longer swims, right?
I think Cameron Bellamy was preparing a swim
that's about that long at one point.
Well, Pablo Fernandez broke the record
for longest distance ocean swim in 2021.
Traveling 155.3 miles in 26 hours.
Incredible.
And then we know Neil Ageous.
The guy who swam from Italy to Malta in 52 hours,
that was a 78.48 miles.
That must be 'cause he's an Olympic swimmer.
So that must be the guy that,
'cause later Phelps talked to his coach, I guess.
And they figured it would be 50 hours.
So they must have been talking about Neil's swim.
That must have been part of that calculus there.
Maybe, maybe not.
I think he could do it.
I think that what would be cooler would be to have him
try to go for a record, in the English channel
or try to find one of these crossings to do first,
you'd have to do some training anyway.
So you'd have to do long swims to prepare.
You couldn't just do the 100.
So wouldn't it be cool if he decided to
go for the triple crown,
the record of the FKT and some of these channel swims.
I'm telling you people who cover channel swimming
would really that.
I'm sure that's gonna be big motivation for him.
I mean, let's be honest here,
could he do it?
Of course he could do it.
Like if Michael Phelp set his sights on a goal this,
he's going to accomplish it.
If he says he could do it, he can do it.
But here's the thing, this is never gonna happen.
Like this is not a real thing.
You know, I love that there's news articles about this,
as if he's actually contemplating it.
He is living his best life right now.
He has accomplished everything there is to accomplish.
Like could he?
Yeah, if he wanted to put his time into this,
but why would he do that, he looks fit.
He's enjoying his kids.
He's going to golf tournaments.
'Cause the inside milk, man, he needs something else.
I dunno.
He needs the primal nature.
But how long...
Listen, first of all,
what ocean and where in,
what is his longitude and latitude here?
Is it cold water, is it tropical water?
Is there chop?
What are we talking about?
Well, I mean, if he's planning on doing...
He's not planning on it.
He's not.
It's, I love the whole conversation.
Like imagining that he's actually planning for this.
If he decided to.
He tweeted that and then he never thought about it again.
Most ly.
But if he decided to take it on, I think you,
you end up having to pick a window and within that window,
you deal with the conditions as they are.
Like, that's how it usually goes.
But where in the world
would you set your sites on doing this?
Like where would his first window be?
Well, first of all, geographically where?
I should ask you that because you've done ultra events.
I usually interview people after they've done them,
but I want-
But what do you want?
You want relatively warm water and you want calm water?
Not necessarily, if you're gonna try to do,
the challenges that I know of,
the best, biggest swims.
I mean, you could do,
he could go to Hawaii to start there,
but the currents can be really rough there.
Wherever you go there's going to be current,
there's going to be tides.
So, at some point-
What you wanna do is swim in within
the Gulf stream current and have it just carry you.
Right, you want the...
Yeah, right.
With maximum speed.
But those conditions can be rough too.
I mean, that doesn't always work.
I think-
And he would have to put on quite a bit of weight
for buoyancy and for warmth.
'Cause even if you're in warm water,
let's say the water's 76 degrees,
that's still considerably colder than your body temperature.
And a lot of your energy goes towards maintaining
core body temperature, right?
So you don't wanna be expending a ton of energy
to stay warm.
So that's why a lot of these open water marathon swimmers,
they look they're outta shape
because they have so much body fat on them.
There's a movement now though, within a water swim.
That was thought to be true, but it's not as necessary
as you think, you don't have to carry as much weight
as it was thought.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's some people who don't think,
I mean, Antonio s his bio print,
but there's others that are preparing swims that
they don't necessarily look Michael Phelps looks,
but in a Speedo,
but they're not necessarily looking too overweight.
Well, the best line in this CBS article
is how it ends at the very end.
(Rich laughs)
As of now,
there doesn't seem to be actual plans for Phelps
to attempt Young Thug's challenge.
Yes.
Way to bury the lead bear.
I think Young Thug is onto something.
I don't know if he tweeted this from jail.
You think Young Thug was actually challenging him?
He was asking a question.
What I think we should start doing,
is have Young Thug
go around challenging athletes to ultra events.
Like whoever he's rooming with-
He's in charge.
He and his roommate-
Of dispensing with challenges.
Dispensing challenges to the world.
He should be the commissioner of Ultra.
While he's awaiting trial.
Yes.
Young thug, you could be the commissioner of Ultra
and you can create events and go around
and you just tap people with Twitter,
tap 'em and said, "You Rich Roll, I've read about you.
"Great book by the way.
"Now you are going to swim Catalina."
Okay, right?
See, this is why we need social media.
Yes, yes, this is the good side of social media.
Okay.
Should we talk about this 70 year old lifeguard?
Which one?
The guy at the Jersey shore.
Ah, the Jersey shore lifeguard.
You know what I'm talking about.
Yes, you're talking about Eric Greensmith.
I am talking about that very man himself.
This popped up on Instagram,
under the Wall Street journal page at WSJ.
This guy, Eric Greensmith, who-
Looks great.
He looks amazing.
He's a retired anesthesiologist, I think.
Was worried about getting bored in retirement.
So as his career started to wind down last year,
he started getting into shape
and started dreaming about recapturing some of his
teenage years by returning to becoming a lifeguard
on the Jersey shore.
He trains for it.
There's all these tests that you have to pass.
Like you gotta run in the sand
and do some kind of routine, and he passed all of those.
And there he is sitting in the lifeguard chair,
saving lives.
There he is, man.
It's shades of Jim McConica,
and the other old heads that I see in Malibu.
You know who Jim McConica is, right?
No.
Jim McConica was a collegiate swimmer at USC.
And his claim to fame is he beat
Mark Spits in some collegiate race.
And then fast forward he was 50 and working,
I think he owned some car dealerships
or something in Ventura,
and he was all outta shape.
And he was kind of disgusted with himself
and he decided to swim, break the record from Catalina.
But now he's something 70.
I covered him when he and the deep Enders did some
channel swims in the Channel islands.
And he at one point held every record
of all the channel islands.
And he's, I think he's 70 plus now.
And when he decided to become a lifeguard again,
I forget how old, I think he was a little bit after 50,
he won that race.
He still can compete with the top guys in speed
in swimming and running.
That's pretty cool.
How do you think he would measure up against Dr. Greensmith?
I think he would defeat Mr. Greensmith.
Dr. Greensmith, sorry.
I got a soft spot spot in my heart for this guy.
Oh yeah.
Check him out.
But I mean MMcConica is a different level.
I get it.
It's cool though.
Like I applaud this.
Do you think-
I think it's cool that the Wall Street journal
decided to write this really cool article.
I love it, I love it.
You know, it's interesting 'cause as we get on in age,
you kind of wanna create new skills,
get new skills, get back to,
you do feel the pull to do something of use
that's different than feeding the chaos machine.
I think about those different things.
And age is just a number.
Yes.
Your greatest challenges await you.
They do?
Okay.
Voluntary challenges.
Oh, good, because I've been through some challenges.
Some of them I'm not eager to go through again.
Life has a tendency to doll things out.
It does.
We don't get out of this thing alive.
No, no, no, nobody does.
Expect more challenges.
This morning I stared death right in the bloody mouth.
What happened?
Someone texted me a picture of a beach dolphin.
Chaos.
I stared at it-
At work.
And I meditated on it.
Did you?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's how I confront death on a near daily basis.
That's your am Omar fatty.
That's my am Omar Foti.
What's that?
The stoic phrase for death is,
what does it translate to?
I feel Ryan Holiday...
I feel Ryan holiday stares at dead animals
on his Instagram every morning before he does a stoic.
I don't think so.
No?
I love his stoic.
He has some practice around that,
but I don't think that's what it looks .
(Adam laughing)
Anyway, let's switch gears.
We're going into the gutter here.
Can I talk about a TV show I watched?
Is this the time or were you doing that later?
Oh, let's do the main topics.
Oh, so the main topic.
The main topics first.
Yeah, we're an hour and a half into this thing
when we're hitting our main subject here,
but hey, this is Roll On, right?
This is what happens in Roll On.
So I thought as we
slowly inch towards the 10 year anniversary of this podcast.
When is that?
It would be in November at some point.
Late November, I think.
It would be good to kind of reflect on
some things that I've learned as a result of this journey
that I've been on.
So I just jotted down some thoughts,
a few pillars of things that I've learned
from podcasting and life and athletics,
business sobriety.
Lessons not just applicable to podcasting
or being a podcaster or being a content creator,
but honestly, and for anyone, for any purpose.
And I think how many did I come up with?
We were cramming to get this podcast together.
Maybe I'll come up with five things.
And I came up with one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine.
Oh, I came up with 12.
So it's the 12 steps, perfect.
Rich Roll's 12 steps.
Roll On 12 steps.
Yes, I don't know how much time we wanna spend on this.
We can go through them quickly.
But the main thing is-
Would you me to try to poke holes to them or just?
You can, I want this to be conversational, Adam,
I told you that.
The first thing is to invest in your curiosity.
And I think that's not to be confused with
follow your passion, it's to pay attention to yourself.
Like what are you naturally curious about?
And to learn to honor that
and to pull on those threads and be open
to where they might lead you.
And often they're not dramatic lightning bolt
types of things,
but I think being in a mindset and cultivating a practice
of honoring your curiosity has been a huge piece
in how this show went from idea to what it is today.
And I think it's applicable to anything that you choose
to invest your time in.
Because if you're not naturally curious about
where that time investment is going,
then it's probably not gonna work, right?
Like if you have to be curious about the work
you're pursuing, the endeavors that you're investing in.
Stay curious.
Yeah, could you write a great book
or a great article if you're not curious
about the material that you're investigating?
No.
Of course not, right?
Can you achieve an athletical if you aren't curious about
what that journey is gonna reveal about
who you are and where it might lead?
Maybe not one-
You could, you could force yourself to,
but it's not gonna be a sustainable thing.
Right, it might be a one off.
And this podcast is really built on curiosity.
I mean, you wanted to talk earlier about
how I choose the guests.
And it's really all about curiosity.
It's a gut instinct thing.
It's not, oh, here are the people with the big books
that are coming out
or here's the people who've expressed interest in coming on,
at this point, it's not about,
who can I get, it's about who's right.
And who's right often doesn't match up
with who's most popular
or who's got the biggest thing going on.
It's about who I'm naturally curious to learn from,
who I feel a gravitational pull towards.
And that's really been the guiding principle or light.
And it's all about curiosity.
Love it.
Second thing, listen, Adam,
you need to hear this, preparation.
Oh.
Preparation.
There are no shortcuts to anything.
You can't cram for a competition.
You can't fake readiness, in order to be present,
in order to be able to execute to the best of your ability,
I cannot overemphasize the importance of preparation.
And in the context of this podcast, I would say on average,
maybe between six to eight hours goes into each guest.
Reading their books, listening to other podcasts
they've been on, reading all the material that I can find.
Background material, news articles, blog posts, et cetera,
and then synthesizing all of that material,
coming up with an outline.
Like I probably go way too far on the preparation thing,
but it's that thing, if you're an actor,
you can't just memorize the lines,
they have to become so rote that you forget them.
And you can show up and be present for the performance.
Similarly, I have to digest all of this
and allow it to kind of percolate in my unconscious mind
so that when I show up to do the podcast,
I'm not reliant upon looking on notes
even though I have the iPad open in case
I have a brain fart or something that.
And I just trust in the preparation and try to be as present
as possible and allow it to be what it wants to be.
But I think what you see are a lot of people faking
the preparation part and trying to kind of,
get through certain experiences and play it off
as if they had prepared.
But you can always tell.
Yeah, 100%.
I mean, I'm all about-
It's a short term versus long term thing.
Sorry, go ahead.
No, yeah, I'm all about the over researching
when I'm writing something,
I always over research, talk to too many people.
I have too many people's quotes that
I wanna get in there that I can't always do.
You feel bad about it sometimes
because you can't get to everything,
but so it creates this other problem,
but in the end it always delivers better material.
So I think in media, preparation is key, six to eight hours
'cause it seems you put in,
I wouldn't have been surprised if it was 30 hours
based on some of the interviews you get into.
Yeah, I mean, and it depends,
it depends on, with authors it's generally more.
'Cause you have to consume their books and all of that.
But and this is applicable to everything.
Like if you're gonna be an athlete,
you wanna show up for your competition prepared.
Like you don't wanna be trying to get away with something
that you actually didn't earn.
And all the things that you seek through
participating in a competition,
the enhanced sense of self and pride and all of that,
are really a function of preparedness.
Like if you didn't really put the preparation in,
and you kind of get away with it,
even if you get the good result,
you're not getting that feeling.
You're not getting that enriched experience
that you would have had you put yourself on the line
and tried your hardest.
Which means investing in that preparation piece.
Love it.
Next thing, listening.
Most people are terrible listeners.
If you can master listening, the art of listening,
you're already gonna be way ahead in just about
everything important in life.
I think that's true.
I'm sorry, what'd you say?
See, I know.
This is why Roll On never works.
(Adam laughs)
Right?
I agree.
When you can match the preparation with listening,
I think, people ask me,
give me some advice about how to conduct an interview
or how to do a podcast.
It's follow your curiosity, there's only one you.
Be super prepared for what you're gonna do,
and then show up and listen.
And I feel so many people are in their own heads
or thinking,
in the very narrow context of podcasting,
so many hosts, they're not listening to their guests,
they're just waiting to ask the next question,
or they're just biting their time until they can tell
their story about their take on something-
And not just in podcast,
you see that on television interviews,
you see it all over.
And it's terrible, right?
Yeah, it's not the best interviewing.
The best interviewing is when you can find a spot
that you can dive deeper,
you can find a little rabbit holes, burrow into 'em.
But also if you're taking that to daily life...
If taking the listening piece,
most people are terrible Listeners,
how would you transfer that?
I'm less skilled in the real world than I am.
I don't believe that.
Yeah, it's about being present, right?
Are you actually listening to the people
that you're engaging with during the day?
And that's definitely
something that I still need a lot of work on.
I'm busy and I'm trying to get from one place to the next
and I don't really wanna sit and listen to
what somebody's trying to tell me
when I'm perceiving them to be an obstacle
to where I'm actually going.
So I think it's inextricably linked with
trying to be in the moment.
And also that's another thing that
the phone get in the way of, right?
Good listening skills.
'Cause we're constantly-
I listen to my phone really well.
Yeah, everyone listens to their phone to the tip top.
Yes.
But yeah, that idea of over distraction
gets in the way of it.
So that's something
we now have to be especially conscious of.
And I think we always had to, but good listeners,
the less you talk, the more you hear more.
The next thing is consistency,
and this is just applicable to everything in life as well.
Whether you're an athlete or professional,
whatever it is that you're trying to improve at,
consistency is the most underrated and important piece
in the whole equation.
In the context of this podcast,
consistency has been everything
just keep moving forward.
Every week you put up an episode,
they're not all gonna be home runs,
just keep moving,
let go of perfection and create a sustainable model
that factors in self care
so that you're in the best position to continue doing
the thing for as long as you remain curious
and passionate about it.
And on the subject of preparing for guests,
I listen to a lot of podcasts, right?
If a guest is coming on,
I'll check out some other podcast appearances they've done
to get a sense of,
who they are or some backstory.
And what I found, not all the time, but
there's a large percentage of hosts
who are either ill prepared,
we talked about earlier or who are not listening,
just waiting to ask the next question or to tell their story
or in certain cases, it's great.
But then I realized that host is no longer podcasting.
Like this was from a couple years ago and they quit
or they stopped because they couldn't maintain consistency
because they couldn't find a way to make it sustainable.
Like that's my only inference.
So consistency is super important.
And that means creating a system that is sustainable.
So paying attention to how you've set everything up.
And this is, I've had to learn from my own mistakes,
starting off, trying to do everything,
being super perfectionist about everything and then learning
how to let go and empower team members and,
create a schedule
that has allowed us to batch work
and schedule way in advance so that everybody has
an enhanced quality of life,
and then taking time off at the end of the year
so I can reboot, all of that has been huge,
so that I can remain as curious and as excited
about doing this thing 10 years after it's begun.
I love it, and that's for sure,
hallmark of anyone in the creative arts consistency
is paramount because most of the time
you won't even get anywhere for the first five years.
So if you give up in that period of time, then-
Yeah, and on that note, patience, right?
Yeah, you don't get anywhere in five years.
Like we hear all this stuff about,
oh, to change a habit you need 28 days.
Like, first of all,
I think it's probably more a hundred days,
but that aside, if you wanna be good at anything,
it's gonna take 10 years.
I think a decade is really the best metric
that I've seen in order to go from not necessarily beginner,
but from competency to
maybe not mastery, but true competency.
Like 10,000 hours becomes 10 years for you.
Whatever it is.
Like, I don't know if you can be that reductive about it,
but things take time.
And you can only rush things so much.
So instead of trying to rush it, just understand,
this is what you're in for, relax into it,
build over time.
Whether you're trying to build a business,
develop a client base,
whatever you're trying to get good at
it's important to think in decades,
not in days or months or years.
It's very tough
when you have this dream and you're young,
and you don't really see God seems so far away.
Yeah, I remember-
I mean, if you're a new lawyer, it's gonna be 10 years
before you have a book of business and you're kind of
well regarded as being somewhat expert
in your specific field.
I'm sure the same is true if you're a doctor.
If you're an engineer and certainly, as a podcast.
We're at 10 years now, when we started, we were small.
Now we're larger.
I still have tons to learn, I would not consider myself
to have mastered this at all.
Like I try to approach it with a beginner's mind.
But yeah, it took 10 years to go from where we were
to where we are today.
And that's just the deal.
When I was a swimmer, it took me from age 10 to 20.
Good, obviously there's some physical development in there,
but that was a 10 year period.
And with podcasting, it's been from 2012 to 2022.
You know, it's funny,
in the end of 2004, beginning 2005,
I went to Indonesia for the second time.
And I met up with Elizabeth Gilbert,
who I had met my previous trip a few months earlier,
six months earlier, we were all there.
And my sister was with me and we all went to go see KATU,
I forget his last name,
but one of the holy men that she consulted
that's in Epray love.
And so she went to see him and then she took me to see him.
And he did his whole thing
where he's kind of tells your fortune.
He predicted the success of you pray love by the way.
And he looks at me
and he says, I forget exactly what went down, but he said,
"You're trying to build something."
And he goes, "It's going to happen, it's going to happen.
"You're gonna achieve great success at 47 years old."
This was 2004, so I was 33.
I think I just turned 33 and I was bummed, man.
I was so bummed.
You know, I was like God, that's a long time.
Like I could barely make rent at 33.
I'm thinking, how am I gonna make rent for 16 years?
That's where my head went.
This is how kind of fucked up I was thinking, but it's true.
I mean, it was scary to hear that.
I didn't hear that just keep going for 17 years.
I heard I haven't even been doing it-
You could have interpreted that as
relax a little bit.
Right, but I'd only been trying for five years, you know?
And it had been hard, you know?
And so now I'm looking all the way to that period of time.
But when I was 47,
right before I turned 47, I think it was right...
Yeah, right before I turned 47 Can't Hurt Me, came out.
Wow, wow.
I wonder if this guy's that right all the time.
I don't know.
Sorry, I have it on airplane mode.
But the thing is if he's wrong, no one remembers.
It's when he is right that you remember.
That's the thing.
How right are you all the time?
But that's pretty right, I mean 47.
Isn't that wild?
It's pretty cool.
Yeah, so there you have it.
Patience is the point.
Next thing, process over results.
You gotta fall in love with the process, Adam.
That's what he was telling me.
Or that's how I was gonna say
that's what he should have told you.
Yeah, but when you're talking about writing,
the process can be torturous sometimes,
but you do have to stay true to it because,
when you're talking about writing,
the more you can get into the process and be there,
it gives time for the beauty to come through.
And it's true of everything.
The more you're in it for the process,
for the right reasons, then the results,
which you care about become less mission critical.
'Cause you're not necessarily doing it for the results,
you're doing it to become better at
the thing that you care about.
And I think that's super important,
for the mastery of craft.
It's hard though, man.
It's not about what happens because of the thing,
it's the thing itself that matters.
So can you find that thing in your life
that matters so much, that it's more important than
where it takes you.
Or it's actually what matters most is you
and that's your own self development,
and the process is really just
an arena for your self development.
Yeah, it is the engine of that journey.
All the rest of it is pretty much,
it doesn't matter at all.
Like whether you're doing it through athletics,
or through something creative or through business
or through family,
they're all just vehicles for that growth journey.
That's right.
There you go.
And the growth journey, isn't always pleasant.
Generally not, generally not.
When you're coasting, you're not growing.
As you can attest
from the story that you just shared.
Yes, yes.
The next thing is to choose your mentors wisely.
I've been pretty lucky with mentors.
When I was early in my career, I didn't have great mentors.
I could have really used them,
but I found an amazing collection of mentors later in life.
And that's been crucial in all the decisions that I've made
around personal and professional life.
And they don't have to be fancy people,
but you do need people in your life who will give you
honest, clear feedback on your decisions.
And those should be people that are trusted.
They should be few.
And they should always have experience
in the field of advice, they have to have skin in the game.
Like you're not gonna go to your
super successful businessman friend,
who's never been in a healthy relationship
to ask him advice about your marriage, right?
You're gonna find somebody with a really stable,
healthy relationship for that purpose.
You can have different mentors for different purposes.
And I've compiled a really robust, stable,
a board of advisors for all the different kinds of
problems that I run into personally,
that I can run things by.
And it's been huge, you know?
And I think, ancillary to that is the importance
of holding yourself accountable to what you say
you're gonna do, being true to your word, to yourself,
and to the other people in your life.
Like I heard this guy was a legend in 12 step.
My boy, Scott G, when I was very newly sober,
he said to me,
I screwed something up and I had to make an amends,
and I felt terrible about it, and he said,
"If you're gonna eat Crow, eat it hot."
Like take care of your shit,
don't wait around and think it's gonna go away,
deal with it directly and swiftly and honestly,
those sorts of actions,
we're all fallible, we're all gonna make mistakes.
And we're all gonna fall short
of holding ourselves accountable at times.
But when you do misstep to just rectify it as quickly
and as swiftly, and as honestly as you possibly can.
Love it.
I don't have stable of mentors, Rich.
You could tell (laughs).
You said, yeah.
You should.
I know, it's obvious.
I know I should, but I never thought of it that way.
I think I'm gonna build a stable of mentors.
Would you to be in my stable?
I would happily fill that role.
Yeah.
I got a stable one now.
There you go.
Gonna add some more.
Call me anytime, Adam.
The next one is around exploring less traveled waters.
And I think this is sort of interesting.
When I was developing as a swimmer,
I very consciously remember choosing to train for
the 200 butterfly because that was a race
that none of the other kids wanted to do.
And in my mind, I thought, well,
that gives me a better chance of distinguishing myself
because there's less competition there.
And that was correct.
And I think that would hold true for,
oh, here's Ultraman over here,
this crazy long race that not that many people
wanna sign up for.
Like maybe I could distinguish myself there in a way
that would be more difficult if I was just to sign up
for an iron man where it's already very crowded.
And I think in the podcasting sphere,
it's been a similar journey.
Like when we started this show,
podcasting was unripened fruit at the time.
Like it wasn't that competitive,
but I did have a sense,
oh, this is a medium with potential.
And I have an opportunity to get in early
when it's not that competitive and distinguish myself.
So I think extracting from those experiences
and applying them to your own life,
where is that unripened fruit that matches up
with your curiosity that together provides for,
maybe an unassuming opportunity or an opportunity that is,
not getting the attention that it could.
And my experience moving in those directions
has proven to be beneficial.
If you look at all this stuff,
you could see how your background in athletics
completely fed your success because,
you're looking at it very-
The principles are the same.
Yeah.
Consistency, perseverance, hard work ethic.
Showing up, accountability.
Identifying the opportunity.
And then it starts to dovetail into principles of sobriety.
Like the next thing on my list is
gratitude and impermanence,
understanding that nothing lasts.
Like I'm very conscious that right now
is an incredible time for the show, for my life.
But I'm also aware that it's not gonna always be this way.
Like this is a very impermanent thing.
Like it will not always...
We have this sense,
oh, this is the way that it is right now.
It's always gonna be this.
Like I know that it's not,
this has an expiration date on it like everything else.
So in the meantime,
make sure to express gratitude for what you have.
Yes.
To appreciate the moment while you're in it,
rather than to only see that in retrospect later on,
after that moment's passed.
And that's not a default mentality for me.
Like that's something I have to practice to be aware of.
Like celebrate the small victories along the way.
And the big ones,
and understand that the big ones...
As human beings, we have this weird wiring
where we think, oh, that was great.
So it's always gonna be great or that was bad,
so it's always gonna be bad.
Like everything is in flux all the time.
Recency bias.
Yeah, recency bias.
Not taking anything for granted.
Not creating expectations one way or the other
around what it's gonna be tomorrow.
Love it.
You know, which kind of segues into the next thing,
which is loved ones first.
And this is a recurring kind of theme on the podcast.
I've had many guests recount a version of this notion that,
every deathbed regret orient around a lament
of time not spent with the people that you love.
Like how many times have you heard that?
A lot.
Right?
Yes.
And how well do we practice that?
You're asking me how I practice?
When we get caught up in the chaos machine.
I'm always in my head, man.
Yeah, it's hard, right?
Kids, partners, friends.
Are they getting the best of your time and attention
or are they getting the scraps at the end of the day
because you're tired and you've
already expanded that energy.
I could be a better a listener.
Me too, right?
I mean this list isn't a list of things
that I'm mastered and I'm now telling you,
these are things that I'm working on myself
that I'm very fallible at.
And then continuing in the kind of sober trajectory here,
it's all about contribution.
What are you giving back in service?
How are you empowering other people?
And this is a drum that I've banked many times
here on the podcast.
Well, I think you do this.
I mean, I think the-
It's yes or no, I mean-
Audience here would tell you that you do.
Right, but this is also a for-profit venture
at the same time.
And it's finding those things of,
how can you merge those things?
Like there's pure service, and then there's,
you can make an argument that this is in service
to other people, it's in service to myself too,
if I'm being honest.
Right, right.
But I think,
understanding that whatever you invest your time in,
you must also find a way to make sure that it's also
about something bigger than yourself,
something that allows you to give back in return
for the gift given.
And I think ancillary to that is this idea of practicing,
entering all scenarios
from a perspective of what you can give,
what can you positively contribute
rather than what you can extract, what you can get,
how you can get one over on other people or get a leg up,
which goes to this idea of long term strategy
versus a short term approach.
Like, yes, if you go into a meeting
and you're trying to one up somebody,
maybe you win that battle,
but ultimately you're gonna lose the war.
And the war always goes to the person
who leads with gratitude, who is giving back,
who is contributing more than they're extracting.
And I think that that is, again,
this is something that this is not about podcasting.
This is about, how do you conduct yourself in the world?
When you enter into a conversation with somebody
or a social setting or a meeting or an exchange
with your kids or your partner, what is your mindset?
Are you trying to contribute?
Are you trying to improve the environment that you're in?
Or are you looking to get what's yours and win?
Yes.
You looking to win, Adam?
Not that often, no.
Yeah, I don't see you like that.
I'm not that person,
but I think that I like to build rapport.
For me a win is when rapport is built.
Like, that's why you have me here, I'm the rapport guy.
You feel the rapport?
A little bit, I'm trying.
You feel it?
It comes and goes.
I feel like we have a rapport.
No, we do, of course we do.
Oh, I mean, I'm definitely not one of those,
I've always thought that,
obviously it's a foundation of the economy,
is the market economy.
But the idea of having to profit the most off every deal
I think which is a product of the stock market, right?
I mean, it's a product of all of that.
And then there's a cascade down.
Even small businesses end up in that same trap,
even though they don't have investors to please.
But they're always trying to get until,
even if they're not trying to make a profit,
like Amazon didn't for years,
they were trying to maximize the market.
So there's a greed element there to get the most.
I've never been the guy that looks to get the most.
No, you're not a zero sum guy.
That's not me.
The universe is infinitely abundant.
I think that we can all,
group up and have more together.
But that doesn't mean
that I don't fall into those traps though.
Yeah.
I mean, one of the greatest gifts of this podcast
is it has provided this opportunity
for me to pursue a living that feeds my family.
But there is this other aspect of it,
it feels good to know that
I'm trying to contribute something positive.
And the marriage of those two things has created
this vocation that I just feel so lucky.
Like, I can't believe I get to do this.
And there's a feeling that you get when you know
I'm trying to do good,
even if I'm not succeeding necessarily,
like the intention is there.
And hopefully once in a while,
the product is there as well.
Well, that's what's cool about kind of creative endeavors
and media in particular is
when your goal is a win-win, you can feel that,
like that's the goal here usually,
when you're sitting down with somebody.
You're not trying to take 'em apart.
You're trying to share what they have that's of value
to people and to explore it for yourself.
And that's always gonna be benefit to the show
and a benefit to the subject and a benefit to the audience.
So it's a win, win, win.
And so if you're trying to go into things with win,
win versus win, right?
Which is definitely your vibe here.
Definitely why we connect, I think, that's the key.
Yeah.
I think, yeah, 100%.
I mean, I'm imagining a listener saying,
well, you found this podcasting thing, you're lucky.
Like I don't have that thing.
Like, how do you find that thing for yourself?
Like I'm not saying people should become podcasters,
but there has to be something that you gravitate towards
when you cultivate that curiosity,
that over time can develop into something that is
both a pursuit that nourishes you,
but also nourishes others.
And kind of bring it back into the context of
the many guests that we've had here.
David Goggins would tell you that
motivation and inspiration are fleeting.
They're not sustainable sources of energy.
And Tom Bill would say,
instead of trying to rely on motivation and inspiration,
you need to find a quest,
and how you define that is up to you.
But to me, a quest means
attaching to something bigger than yourself.
Like whether that's a problem that needs solving
or a need that needs being met.
Scott Harrison says, don't fear work with no end.
And like Mike Fremont, the centenarian says,
make your life about service.
And that's gonna look different for every single person,
but there's something really beautiful
and indelibly true about that.
100%.
Yeah.
Final thing, number 12.
12, the 12th.
The 12th, I wouldn't call them steps.
These are ideas I jotted down this morning.
Let's not get crazy.
Why you put that much thought into this 12 points.
On the preparation thing, less preparation for today.
12 points of light.
Six to eight hours did not go into this.
This particular show?
Yeah.
But they don't need to.
It's a mad scramble.
I wake up Monday morning and then we frantically get on
FaceTime and on the phone, and try to figure out
what we're gonna talk about.
I called you yesterday.
Yeah, you did, we had a call.
I think people would to know
how we put this thing together.
We do not sit down and just decide in the moment
what we're gonna talk about.
No.
We throw in an outline back and forth
over the course of 10 or 12 days.
That ends up in some form of
completion or non-completion.
And then over the weekend we chat on the phone,
we try to mature those ideas.
And then Monday morning we get back on the phone,
we finalize the outline.
We make some last minute hectic notes,
and then we roll the dice.
But I would say we put, I mean,
basically over the course of two weeks, I make notes
every time I come across something interesting,
like I throw it in the outline or in my notes app
on my phone.
So I'm constantly, always like thinking about-
Yeah, yeah, I have a notes app always going.
This time it's just been a scramble for me
in the last four weeks.
So I've been less available than
my typically always available self.
It's okay.
'Cause you have private secret projects
that you're working on.
You're not allow to talk about.
I got top secret projects that no one will know about.
Ever?
How convenient.
KATU layer, KATU layer.
Adam is unavailable.
He's working on a top secret project
that you'll never-
Next work when he's 67 and it'll be a smash hit.
Alright, final point.
This is another drum that I've beaten many times,
and that is conversation matters.
Because if we can't talk about it, we can't solve it.
And I really believe that,
when we think about the chaos machine and
the episode with Max and the existential problems
that we face individually,
culturally, socially, politically, economically,
the solutions to these problems
begin and end with conversation.
If we can't talk about it, we can't solve it.
We're in a situation right now where there has been
a denigration, a dissolution in healthy discourse.
And if there's one thing that I'm devoted to
in this podcast,
it's endeavoring to have healthy conversations
about things that matter.
Because we do need to talk about these things
and the solution does lie in conversation.
It's not the whole thing,
but if we can't have a conversation about
these important subjects,
we're in no position to rectify the problems that we face.
Too many people out there are trying to win.
Aren't they?
It's not about winning, it's about listening.
It's about compassion, it's about understanding.
Love it.
12 Points.
So there it is, 12 points.
These principles apply to whatever you're thinking about
or striving towards fitness, athleticism,
whatever career path you've chosen, writing books,
being a creative individual, being a parent,
being a partner.
Being a chef.
Yeah, they come, it is interesting.
Like I was writing these down and I was,
well, these are things that I've kind of
learned from podcasting,
but I kind of learned them from being an athlete.
I've learned them being a sober person
for an extended period of time.
I've learned about them being a parent
and a partner, and they all kind of congeal.
So I can't separate one from the other.
But I like that you're analyzing yourself
and what you experience and what you've been through,
like that kind of stepping back
and taking the time to do that is cool.
Like, I just never do that.
And it is healthy to do that, you know?
And if you don't separate yourself from your life
to take the time, then you forget too much,
you don't see as clearly
the principles that have guided your own life,
even if you are guided with some principles that matter
that are true and pure.
If you don't see them it's like
you can't leverage them quite as much.
Yeah, and the way to see them is through meditation
and mindfulness practices and journaling.
Like if you journal enough themes emerge, my friend.
And you start to see your behavior patterns recurring
and you get clarity on what's driving them
and why do I keep doing that?
And when I do this, I get better results.
And why is it hard for me to do this thing?
Or here's a habit that I've changed
or that I need to change.
Like I can't recommend or encourage enough,
people to engage in their version of that process.
I love it.
All right, we're gonna answer some listener questions,
but before we do that,
do you wanna share a couple things that we've enjoyed?
Yes.
Some content recommendations.
Yeah, go for it.
I just wrote about this new series from Jimmy Chin,
and his wife, Chi.
What's her last name?
Buzzerelli.
Buzzereli.
I know how to spell it, I don't know how to say it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Once you say it though, you can get it down.
It's easy.
Anyway, they have this new series through the Nat Geo
Disney plus app for streaming.
It's called "Edge of the Unknown" with Jimmy Chin.
And it is in encapsulation of each episodes its own story.
And basically it came out of, yeah,
this story that I wrote should be up for outside
before this episode drops.
But I had a chance to have a Zoom call with Jimmy.
And he talked about how after free solo came out,
he kept getting approached by people who wanna know
how come these athletes don't feel fear, basically?
Some version of that.
Like, what is it about these guys
they don't feel the fear.
How could Alex be on that wall and not feel fear?
And so this was kind of his way of showing 12,
all of who are the best at what they do,
whether it's a big drop kayaker or a big wave surfer,
is Justine DuPont on there,
or Travis rice, the snowboarder,
you see them all in the moment where they
failed or almost died.
And through that lens,
you also see how much preparation goes into the sport
they do, why they're doing it.
You actually see them as these unvarnished human beings
going through this crazy experience and then coming out
the other side, these stories aren't necessarily new.
They're kind of some amazing stories
from the last 15 years or so
of adventure sports.
Conrad Anchor's heart attack
when he's climbing a mountain is in there.
Jimmy's-
Do they have film documentation of that?
It's amazing footage.
I mean, it looks phenomenal.
Jimmy's Avalanche story, that's in Maru with Jeremy Jones.
That's in there in a much deeper way.
So in the footage,
I can't express enough how great the footage is.
Some of it's the red bull cameramen hanging out of choppers,
but some of it is people with GoPros in the river,
and that kind is even more moving sometimes.
So it's really incredible.
There are only 22 minute episodes, I think,
so real easy to digest.
And it's made for the core audience
all the way through the kind of casual arm share adventures.
Yeah, I would imagine for the hardcore adventure person,
they're already familiar with Jimmy's work
and they know that he's chronicled these various people
and these various challenges,
but the average viewer doesn't know.
Maybe they saw free solo, but how many people saw Maru,
or some of the other stuff that they've done.
I think it's really cool.
I'm looking forward to watching that.
I was meant to be in Anaheim last Friday
to do a fireside with Jimmy and Alex
about the show for some kind of Disney plus upfront event
or something that.
But I couldn't do it, I was too busy.
I'm kind of bummed that I couldn't make it.
Around this new series.
So I'm really looking forward to checking it out.
Yeah, yeah, it's their first four into television.
They've had Oscar wins for free solo.
They made the rescue.
And they have obviously Maru.
The first of many Tai cave productions.
That's my next, yes.
I'm working on something like that right now.
There's a lot in the pipeline there,
but they were the first, I love that documentary.
I feel it should have gotten more attention
than it did, I thought it was unbelievably rendered.
And it is that combination of, yes,
the guy hanging out of the helicopter
with boots on the ground, GoPro cinema verte.
Yes, yes.
That he's exceptional and him and Charlie-
There's nobody him who has
a boot at the top of both fields.
You know, there's just nobody that.
Yeah, cool.
Well, similarly, this is not new,
but I finally got around to watching
a hundred foot wave on HBO.
Oh yeah, man.
And we've talked about it.
I know you watched it a long time ago and you've interviewed
Maya and you've covered Nazare
and everything that's gone on there.
And so I had kind of an arms length understanding
of all of that,
but Garrett McNamara was coming on the podcast
who's the guy who basically pioneered
big wave surfing in Nazare.
And I needed to really,
as part of my six to eight hours-
That's a good one.
I'm gonna watch this.
That's a pleasure cruise.
That's an easy six or seven hours right there.
And this show is unbelievable.
So I told Garrett,
and this episode's not going up for a while,
but I told Garrett that the experience of watching that
was very similar to me interviewing Alex Honald
after he had free soloed L cap.
But a year before the movie came out,
and thinking that I understood what he had done
only to watch the movie a year later and realize,
oh, I don't really understand that at all.
Like, this is way crazier than I ever imagined.
Similarly with the "100 Foot Wave,"
thinking, oh, Garrett,
found this wave and just went over there
and figured out how to surf it.
To discover that he was there two years before
they finally figured out how to safely surf it
and to do it strategically and team building.
Safely.
Yeah, well, he says in the podcast,
he's like, "Surfing Nazare is the safest thing in the world"
or something that.
I was like that's the craziest thing you've ever seen.
(Adam laughing)
That's not true.
It's not the safest thing in the world.
He's like, he's describing these waves.
He gets so animated,
but how much went into team building and research
and strategy and consensus building
and getting the government on board,
and getting the lighthouse opened,
and getting the resources,
putting those pieces into motion
took a long time.
But he understood that,
he understood the only successful way
for him to do this thing was to do all of this
foundation building first,
which was really smart, right?
And obviously ended up being successful
in contrast to when the Brazilians show up and,
think that they're gonna be able to just go out there
and do it and realize very quickly,
oh, that's not gonna work.
I just learned a lot and developed a greater appreciation
for Garrett's level of mastery
and his unique sort of genius.
And I thought the storytelling and the cinematography,
I mean, they just won an Emmy for best cinematography.
It's extraordinary.
How do you get over that?
And they're doing a season two,
which I think they've already shot it, it's already wrapped.
Yeah, right.
I think it's coming out in January or something like that.
I think Garrett McNamara's is one of the greatest leaders
and visionaries in the history of adventure sports.
And I think that,
it's really laid bare in a hundred foot wave
why I feel that way.
So I don't even wanna say anything more about that.
Just watch that if you haven't seen it because-
And watch it in advance of the podcast.
Because his leadership-
The podcast will be better if you've watched it.
It's incredible.
It's challenging, but also very nurturing.
And he gets people to do things
that they never would've thought themselves they could do.
Like he's training local crew.
He knows who to push,
he knows how to find the right people.
But he's training local crew to run
basically safety on jet skis.
Who've never done anything remotely like this.
Wave runners.
Yeah, wave runners.
Anyway, he's a very special individual
and his whole upbringing is special.
I mean, just his backstory is incredibe.
And his wife, Nicole, amazing.
She pops in on the podcast as well.
And Maya now lives there too.
So it's like,
she nearly died there and I think that's safe to say,
it's been out there, I think I wrote about it.
And she nearly died there and she was actually...
Garrett was one of the few big wave surfers or
surf stars that did not ever
say anything negative about Maya.
Like the big surf stars
that were out there saying she's dangerous, whatever,
and were kind of treating her negatively.
Garrett never did that, he always saw her greatness too.
So that's what I'm talking about with the leadership.
Yeah.
Check that out, very cool.
My big recommendation for the week though,
is (indistinct) appearance on John Bernal's podcast,
Real Ones.
Did you listen to this?
No, no.
(both laughing)
Here's another one you didn't listen to.
I missed that one.
Yeah.
I don't normally go around looking at Shire-
I would strongly suggest dialing that one up
for the drive home after the podcast today.
I was very moved by it.
Shire is incredibly,
for people that don't know, he is an actor,
he's suffered problems with addiction
and had a very kind of public meltdown
with some terrible inexcusable behavior.
And he's now in a place where he's really reckoned
with his past and is endeavoring
to the best of his abilities to make amends for his mistakes
and kind of repair his life.
And it's very emotional and powerful.
Like there's something very pure and honest about it,
and captivating.
And perhaps that's in part due to the fact that
Shire himself is a very charismatic individual.
But I found it to be,
especially for anybody who knows somebody
who's struggling with addiction or,
has some connection to that disease
and the wreckage that it causes,
I think it would be healing and instructive to listen to it.
And that's all I wanna say.
I don't wanna spoil it.
And Betal was on the-
It's special, I would say it's special, yeah.
And Betal's-
I mean, Betal is the king.
Like that guy's makes everything that he's in, better.
He was in "The Bear," right?
He was in "The Bear" briefly.
That's a bit of a spoiler,
but I don't know at this point.
Okay, sorry.
"Wolf of Wall Street."
Yeah, amazing.
Like leaps off the screen.
And now of course in "American Jiglo."
Yeah, right.
Did you watch the pilot of this?
I've not seen it yet, no.
But the classic movie that this takes place after the movie,
six years after the movie ends.
Well, it's basically a reimagining of the movie.
Like as if the movie was gonna be a mini series.
All the way down to the blondie,
"Call Me" song, that was part and parcel
of the Richard gear movie.
And I think in watching that pilot,
I was very worried because, I mean,
that movie launched Richard gear's career.
Is it Paul Schrader who directed that?
Like how are they gonna do this as a TV show
set in modern times?
Because that movie is wed to the 80s.
Like the 80s is just it 19 that whole thing.
It's launched in the 80s, you could say.
I won't spoil, I mean, I've only watched the pilot,
but they take it in a pretty interesting direction
and Betal is always just a pleasure to watch.
And he's a very gifted actor,
with an amazing story in his own.
I really wanna get this guy on the podcast.
Not only is he from DC, we grew up near each other.
His backstory is wild.
Like his dad had was a big DC lawyer who then became,
I don't know what the title is, chairman or director,
of the humane society.
He's a big animal rights guy.
And he's got these brothers
who are all super accomplished in their own right.
Like his brother Tom, just married Cheryl Sandberg.
And he's got another brother
who's a huge oncologist at UCLA.
And John was kind of the kid who would get in trouble
all the time and somehow fell into drama
and it spoke to him and he had some teacher or mentor
who knew John needed some help or
he might fall into the wrong crowd and go down
a bad direction and got him hooked up
with this incredible drama school in Moscow.
And so he moved to Russia and lived there and studied acting
in the traditional Russian tradition.
I don't know the name of the school for like,
I don't know, two years or something like that.
And that's where he learned the hardcore,
the Russian school of dramaturgy drama
of acting.
And there's something really pure about that guy
that I think is really special and cool.
That's a journey.
That's called endeavoring into the process,
deep in the process.
Shilah Puff on real ones, check it out.
Shilah Puff.
Be Bjork has a podcast.
Is this a podcast you've listened to Adam?
I've listened to every episode.
I haven't checked this one out yet.
We're on the same page here
'cause I haven't listened to this one yet, but,
I mean, come on,
this has to be on your must listen to-
I need to listen to more podcasts,
is what I'm getting at.
If anybody's gonna revolutionize what we imagine
a podcast could be, I would Bjork at the top of that list.
So out of pure curiosity,
I'm gonna be putting this on my-
Definitely.
Try listen list.
Ever listen to Kona O'Brien's podcast?
I listen that sometimes once.
Once in a while.
What was the mental segue between Bjork and Conan-
Celebrity podcasters?
Yeah, you can't put Bjork and Conan.
That's a weird-
No, but they're both quirky offbeat celebrities.
Yeah, but Bjork is like an artist beyond-
She's legendary, I get it.
So there we go.
All right, that's all I got.
Let's do some listener questions.
(Adam laughing)
Let's do it.
Bjork's podcast.
What I'm learning is I need to listen to more podcasts.
Here we go, Nicole from Dallas.
Hey, it's Nicole from Dallas.
It's frequently discussed on the show
the importance of sleep and implications that poor sleep has
on one's health.
My question is, and I'm going to intentionally generalize,
but what can women do
who go years without sleeping through the night
because of small children,
or those nursing or with a teething baby,
or maybe have multiple children who wake up mom,
because they had a bad dream.
They went to bed or they just needed a drink of water,
or even families that have children with type one diabetes
and have to wake up every night to monitor that child.
Do you have any words of advice for individuals
that go years in a constant state of sleep deprivation?
Love the show, thanks.
How's your sleep deprivation, Adam?
It's still there.
It's been there for a long time.
At one point during my guidebook phase,
I had been crossing so many different time zones
that my circadian rhythms got completely screwy.
And I started waking up in the middle of the night
couldn't get back to sleep
and that's something that's still with me.
And sometimes it flares up worse than others.
And then obviously having Zuma,
whatever progress I had made is kind of shambles, you know?
I had gotten to a point where I was just decided
I'm gonna stay in bed until I get my seven hours,
no matter what, and that helped me a little bit,
but of course sometimes life won't let you do that.
Now that's not an option.
So it's still there, I've had to deal with it.
I know exactly what she's talking about.
I even know what she's talking about specifically here,
'cause Zuma is still not sleeping through the night.
He's still breastfeeds.
So he's still sometimes needs mom,
and it doesn't help for me to go...
I go in there sometimes, doesn't always help.
So I get it.
And your experience is just nothing like
what it's like to be the mom.
No, right, exactly.
To be clear about that.
I mean, let me begin by saying,
I got dragged a bit probably rightfully so,
for not delving more deeply into this specific terrain
when I had Matthew Walker on the podcast,
I apologize for that.
We do have plans to have him back on
for a very directed listener Q&A session.
And this question, because it's come up in comments
to the reels that I've posted with him.
Like, why didn't you ask him about this?
So I do have plans to make sure that he answers
this very specific question,
which is a very circuitous way of saying like,
I'm ill-equipped to answer this question,
I'm not a sleep expert and thus,
not one to reliably opine on this specific question.
And let's face it, I'm not a mom with young kids.
So there's that too as well.
Also there's only so much you can do.
Yeah, that's the thing, like what can be done.
What I will say in the context of doing the best you can,
is at first, you can't change the past,
what has happened in the past,
like okay, you have years of this sleep deprivation,
you can let that haunt you
and you can allow that to exacerbate your anxiety levels.
But let's just put that aside because that has happened
and that cannot be changed.
The important thing is to do your best
within the complicated context of your life,
to not allow the anxiety of that lost sleep in the past,
impair your sleep going forward.
And I think, to begin,
it's important to try to maximize the quality.
Like what can you control?
You have quality and you have quantity.
Right now the quantity is being impaired by circumstances
beyond your control by this young person
who has needs and needs that you need to meet.
But what you can control to some extent
is the quality of the limited sleep that
you can or you are getting.
No devices in bed, no TV in the bedroom,
try to keep the bedroom a bit chilled.
Like don't eat too late at night.
Like all things that Matthew Walker shared on the podcast.
If you can, try to exercise during the day,
even if it's just a little bit or going for a walk,
try to expose your eyes to 10 to 15 minutes of sunlight
upon waking, the Huberman thing
to help set your circadian rhythm.
Try to slowly wind down in the later hours of the day
so that you're gently cajoling yourself into a state
optimal for sleep.
Maybe get an eye mask, if you don't have one.
If you have a little bit of a budget,
invest in some blackout curtains,
because to the extent that you're able to grab a nap
here and there, to have a dark room in order to do that,
will be helpful.
So it's not about trying to find a way to increase
the hours, but again,
increase the quality and help you drift back to sleep
more quickly after being woken up.
If you're gonna get woken up and then you go back to bed,
are you lying there awake or are you able to go back
to sleep more quickly?
If that's a struggle for you,
maybe check out some of these meditation or mindfulness
apps, check out calm app, these sleep stories.
There are podcasts devoted to helping you fall asleep.
Like there's one, I forget what it's called,
this guy just drones on.
Like he does one every day.
And he literally just tells stories
and he goes off on all these crazy tangents,
but he has a very soothing voice.
And I think he's just riffing on whatever comes to mind,
but it actually puts you to sleep
'cause it's purposefully super boring.
Like he's like, well, and then I went to the grocery stores.
Just like nonsense, right?
So yeah, again, are you meditating?
Do you have a mindfulness practice to reduce your anxiety?
Like according to Matthew Walker,
anxiety is such a huge piece here,
a huge impediment to restful sleep.
So if you can reduce that anxiety,
perhaps you can enhance the depth of your sleep,
even if it's limited.
Of course, none of these things are things that
I'm sure you haven't thought of.
Like if you can afford it,
could you possibly get the occasional night nurse?
Could you splurge on that?
Like I realize that isn't within reach for many,
but if it is,
that's probably a worthy investment
indulging once in a while
so that you can get an uninterrupted night of sleep.
Can you get any naps in, can you try to get a nap in?
Again, if you have the eye mask or the blackout curtains,
that's helpful.
Can you trade duties with your spouse or your partner,
or can you set up a schedule
so that every once in a while you get
the occasional full night of sleep,
I don't have a magic bullet here.
I mean, Adam it's been many years since I-
It doesn't fully work that way.
I know, I know it doesn't.
'Cause if you have a night nurse in the house
and they're screaming 'cause they want mom,
that's not going to keep you asleep.
I understand, right?
But for everything I said there's a yeah but.
Right.
So I would say what I'm hearing from this question is,
and this is something that I'm sure you've helped
dealt with before,
but there's such information overload out there.
And sometimes when you hear from these experts
that have their heart is in the right place-
It's all about optimizing.
Some people are like, I can't optimize right now,
and I feel guilty or bad, like I should be.
Exactly, exactly.
Let go of it.
You're a mom with a baby.
Like it's okay, you'll live.
This two shall pass.
Right, it lands as a task
they can't check off.
And so then it feels like-
You're less than or something.
Right, and so what can I do?
And the real answer unfortunately is,
we don't know, but like-
And it's fucking harsh.
There's periods of time in life
that these are the conditions of your life.
And you have to accept them,
obviously, because if you don't,
there's still gonna be your conditions of your life.
And so these are the conditions of life-
And you'll just suffer more.
We try to, I handle mornings
that's one way I do it is that,
I'm the breakfast guy, always.
I take him out of there when he wakes up,
I do, two and a half hours with him.
She gets a snooze and that's how we do it.
That's the best thing I can do for her, for April,
is to make sure that she gets at least attempt a snooze
sometimes 'cause things pop up and she can't
take that morning snooze.
And so then there's that.
But that's what I've been able to do.
And that's the best I can do.
Sometimes I go in there at night and it's worked,
and sometimes not 'cause that's not what he wants.
So I feel for you.
Yeah.
I feel for you, Dallas.
I think maybe just an inhale and an exhale,
and just an acknowledgement that it's hard
and you have to be kind of a superhero to wake up every day
and navigate all of it.
And it's okay.
You're not gonna be able to get these things
that Matthew Walker is talking about,
but be gentle on yourself.
And that doesn't mean you're behind.
It doesn't mean that you're behind the ball
or behind other people or not able to live a great life
or a long life.
'Cause remember all this stuff
is based on percentages anyway and probabilities.
And so there are people who will function just fine,
and your body has a way to
get you through these periods of time.
So when you're looking at probabilities,
and this is what works the best for general population
and most medical analysis is based in probabilities.
It doesn't mean it's gonna be that way for you.
All right, next question.
You don't want me to venture into the probabilities?
No, professor scientist, Dr. Adam.
This is been-
Sleep science expert, Adam Skolnick.
This is Adam Skolnick,
I'm a professor of sleep science at the near-
You're venturing into galaxy brain territory
and I'm trying to save you.
I'm frequently called a neuro scientist,
which isn't the same thing.
Is that near beer?
Neuro scientist.
I'm a neuro scientist.
Let's go to Georgina from Kentucky.
Let's do that.
Hi, Rich and Adam.
This is Georgina calling from Kentucky.
I'm calling after a long weekend of listening
about Eliza Fletcher who was killed
over the weekend after running.
And I wanted to ask you some questions
that my 14 year old daughter is asking me right now.
My daughter recently started running about two years ago
for soccer and was thrilled this summer
to start running by herself on our walking trail.
She runs about anywhere from one to three miles
and carries mace with her.
But after the information from this weekend,
she came into my room last night and said that she's scared.
She doesn't wanna run anymore.
And running on a treadmill doesn't seem the answer for her.
I know you're probably getting lots of questions about this,
but I'm seeking your advice.
Running seems to be what my daughter called her safe place.
And now it feels it's anything but that.
I guess what I'm asking for is advice for
young girls who wanna go running by themselves
without a chaperone.
It's awful that the world has come to this.
Thanks for everything that you do.
I love your shows.
I've been following you for a long time.
And thanks for attending to this voicemail.
This makes me so angry.
You know, this case-
Sucks so bad, yeah.
It's just terrible that
anyone would have to think about this at all.
I mean, everybody deserves to be able to be outdoors,
enjoy the outdoors, nature, go running,
anywhere, anytime without fear.
That is not the world we live in.
And it's such a bummer.
Here's this 14 year old girl who was falling in love
with running and now feels unsafe doing it
for valid reasons.
I mean, what happened to Eliza Fletcher is just horrific.
And I just hate the fact that
we have to keep having conversations around this.
And we talked about it with Hamed Aubrey, of course,
it's just a bummer, man.
You know, what do you say to this?
What do you say to this?
Can I say anything to Georgina and her daughter
that would be helpful
that they haven't already thought about?
I mean, what can you say?
You know, choose your root carefully.
You know, maybe don't run at night,
tell others where you will be,
and when wear, bright colors, reflective gear,
keep that mace.
All of these things are just fear impulse though.
Like the world is a very scary place.
It's a very violent place and you should be afraid
all the time.
And I fucking hate that.
And I say that as somebody of extreme privilege
who goes out running whenever I want, wherever I want,
I've gone running in places all over the world.
I run through skid row and downtown LA,
and I've run through all kinds of crazy neighborhoods
and urban environments,
that I'm familiar with and unfamiliar with
and cities all over the world.
And I've never thought about this.
And maybe I'm naive, but I think I'm also,
incredibly privileged, I don't have to worry about this
in the way that she has to worry about it.
It's very upsetting and it makes me angry.
Like what do you say?
You have to go running with your friends.
Don't go alone.
Well, I think I should-
Choose your hours and your routes carefully.
Yeah, I think Eliza Fletcher,
she was running at four in the morning, so it was dark.
This is not about blaming anything.
Obviously it's a horrific thing that happened
and she should be allowed to run at four in the morning,
any time she wants.
But I think when you're talking about a 14 year old girl,
I mean, I wouldn't want
even my son at 14 to be running at night.
I think that the real world is,
you probably shouldn't run at night.
Not maybe, but definitely not.
So that's one thing you can do.
That doesn't mean the world is a dangerous place.
It is a dangerous place.
Doesn't mean that should be the first thought
that runs through your mind.
But there's things you can do.
And running with friends is a cool thing.
Doesn't have to be a bad thing, could be a cool thing.
It just is not-
It's not the same.
It's more challenging to be spontaneous.
I have an hour, I'm gonna go out, like okay.
It does, it does.
But there are things that you can use technology
to be helpful here.
Like Strava has a live tracking,
sort of option on there.
You can be broadcasting where you are to your loved one
so they can see where you are.
Or you can share your location with someone using,
Find my iPhone, if you have an iPhone.
So anyone can find you and see where you are in real time.
You know, those are things that you could do.
I mean, we were talking about this earlier.
You had mentioned taking a self-defense class,
which could be a cool fun thing to do.
That would help soccer with balance.
It would also help-
All those things.
Running is usually a part of martial arts classes.
But the bigger question is,
especially from a parent child perspective,
is what are we cultivating in this young person?
Like, are we telling them
that the world is a very scary place
and they should be afraid all of the time?
Or are we trying to instill in them,
a sense of self sufficiency,
like yes, be wary, but
don't live your life out in fear of bad things happening
at all times.
I don't think that's a healthy message
to be kind of pounding your into your kid.
And to that point, we both kind of,
came across this Arthur Brook's article in the Atlantic,
"Friend of the Pod".
Which is titled yeah, "Friend of the Pod."
Don't teach your kids to fear the world.
So you wanna talk about this article a little bit.
Yeah, I thought it really applied well
to this question.
It's very applicable to this question.
Especially 'cause Georgina seemed she was kind of
at her wits end with this whole thing too.
She seemed very sad in that space.
And so it's really important.
How do you process this kind of information
and how do you then teach it going forward,
especially if your daughter's coming to you.
And the premise here it's not about any specific case.
It's a parsing of the science around happiness,
which is what he does.
One thing that he says here is teaching the world
is dangerous, encourages a negative primal belief.
A primal belief is a fundamental belief that can then color
opinions, attitudes, and behaviors going forward.
So if you're teaching your kids that the world is dangerous,
that can also make them less tolerant of others,
in particular, or it could make them actually less safe.
Because if you think the world's always dangerous,
then often your perception of what truly is dangerous
is off, and so that's another thing that they've found.
It's the same problem that I think Jonathan Hay
wrote about in teaching young people
that ordinary interactions are dangerous,
for example, people who try to say
speech is a form of violence, for instance,
or speech is inherently dangerous.
That hinders intellectual and emotional growth,
that can lead to black and white views
of how the world works good versus evil.
And that makes people more anxious.
So we wanna stay away from that.
I thought that was an interesting takeaway here.
But the bottom line is,
being a kid in America has never been safer.
If you look at the stats, since 1935 number of childhood
deaths between ages of one and four fell from 450 to 30
per 100,000, now that's mostly because of medical science,
but it just shows that the fatalities for young people
have gone way, way, way, way down.
And it's fallen half just since 1990.
It's been cut in half again.
So that's important to know.
It's not what happened to Eliza Fletcher
is a common thing, it's very uncommon.
Yeah, and I think that plays back into
the discussion around the chaos machine.
Because as horrible as these events are,
and in no way do I want to minimize them whatsoever,
when we see them go viral on social media
and there's a discourse that begins to swirl around them,
it impulses our lizard brain to believe that
this is something more propagate than it actually is
in terms of frequency.
And we're lured into this sense that
this is happening everywhere all the time.
And that leads us down the path to being very afraid
of everything all the time, which is not healthy.
Having some objective context around,
how often this is happening,
and how safe or unsafe our streets actually are,
is a really good tool to help understand that
things may not be quite as bad or as unsafe as they seem.
And again, back to like,
I say that as this privileged white guy, right?
Like I don't...
Arthur Brooks is not saying don't bring up threats.
So when you're talking about a 14 year old girl
going out on the streets and running at night,
that needs to be dealt with,
that's not necessarily the safest activity
in the history of the world these days, unfortunately.
So it is important to address that,
but also to keep it in the proportion of,
this isn't necessarily the most dangerous thing
in the world either.
It's not a foregone conclusion that anything
is going to happen to you negatively.
More likely the worst thing to happen to you
if you're out at night by yourself
is you could turn an ankle and have to figure out
your way home if you don't have your phone.
So it's like that's probably the more likely thing
that could happen to anybody at night.
The impulsing is what Brooks calls it, negative primals.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and instead he's offering that
we should instead teach love primal.
What he's calling love primal.
Exactly, when there is a threat that there can be...
You always talk about control the controllables, right?
To me it's controlling controllables to
keep running a part of your life,
it goes to sometimes maybe it does have to be a treadmill.
'Cause that's what you have to do that day.
Maybe you can run on track at school, after school.
Maybe you can run around the track.
Maybe there's other ways to do it.
Maybe you can get onto the trail and keep doing it.
Maybe it is you bring friends into it,
or have a self-defense class.
It's not how you fell in love with running,
but it can help you stay in contact with running.
And then when it's night in summertime
and the light stays out later,
then you have a much bigger time
to where you can engage in it.
So I think also making sure
that the kids understand that these limitations
don't have to be entirely limiting.
They could just require you to think and adapt.
Or chronically anxiety producing.
Right, right, right.
Well said.
Thank you.
All right, are we gonna do this third question?
We don't have to.
We could, well, let's see what comes out.
I didn't write the ideas down.
I'm interested in how you're gonna answer this.
Yeah, I can see, that's not fair.
I don't even know how I'm gonna answer it.
Hi, everyone at the RRP.
This is Jonathan from Vancouver,
answering your clarion call for listener questions.
Huge shout out to the whole team for such a great podcast.
A few props, Adam, I always your use of Waterman.
And how you talk about your relationship to the ocean.
Rich, like all listeners,
endless gratitude for such a great show.
And as a teacher, I how you use the words,
rubric and parse,
keeping it a little bit light in the spirit of a Roll On,
my question for you both is,
in the time that you have known each other,
what's the most important thing that you have learned
from each other?
Thank you for such a great show and have a great day.
Rubric and parse, Jonathan, I feel seen.
Yes, I think one thing I've learned from you
is how to use $20 words in a complete sentence.
Yeah, probably it's just a mask, Adam.
I want people to think I'm smarter than I am.
What have we learned from each other, Adam?
I don't know, do I need a new cohost?
Like what are we doing here?
What have I learned from you?
Is that where you're going here?
I don't know.
This is my intervention.
By what rubric are we going to
deconstruct this question?
Well, you, it's easy though,
for me to have learned from you because,
I didn't realize how possible
some of these endurance feats were.
And so I put you in that same category.
You also brought amazing stories
like today, we talked about Ken Rideout,
but the David Goggins interview, I first heard it here.
And even before that, having met you,
just understanding that these things are possible,
that it's possible to swim and run and ride your bike
these lengths.
I didn't even really know that was super possible before.
So for me, that expands what is possible in all realms.
'Cause once you start to be more open and flexible
in your open minded, I guess,
to what's possible in any one track, it really,
it allows you to see how limiting your thinking
can be elsewhere.
So I think that you're one of those people
that shows me that.
Yeah, thank you for that.
I appreciate that.
I hope that can continue as your comment.
As you're answering that,
I was reflecting on when we first met, so we share
a literary agent and your book, "One Breath" was coming out
and I read it and I loved it and I invited you on.
And what I remember,
I don't even remember what we talked about.
All I remember is, it was a vibe check.
Like I just remember that I vibed with you
and it was really easy to talk to you.
And it's not we became immediate best bros
and hung out all the time.
But I made a mental note,
I was like, I really talking to that guy.
It was really easy to talk to him, he was really smart.
Like we had a rapport that was very natural.
And I think, I've learned to
appreciate how rare that is as somebody who sits across
and talks to a lot of people.
Like sometimes you sit in and it just flows and it's easy,
but more often than not,
you gotta insert yourself and figure out,
how do I connect with this person?
How do I make this work?
And sometimes you can get there and sometimes you can't,
but with you, it's always easy to talk to you.
And I think that that is underappreciated
and an undervalued, magical, mystical thing
that you can't create.
Like it either exists or it doesn't.
So when the prospect of trying this new format came out
like immediately, I was like, we gotta get Adam.
Like I remembered that experience.
And I was,
you can't put a dollar figure on that kind of thing.
And I think what I value most about you is,
you have such a breadth of wisdom and experience,
and intellectual capacity and curiosity.
Like you read tons of stuff
and you're interested in things that matter.
And you care about people and we have shared interests
that don't align perfectly,
but that's what makes for a cool thing here.
And this friendship has developed
as a result of doing the show.
And as I get older, I've learned to,
how important friendships are and I've reflected
on friendships that I haven't invested in
as much as I could have or should be.
And I just wanted to let you know that
I appreciate our friendship.
It's fun to do this thing,
but it's our friendship that exists outside of this.
And doing this has been an absolute joy and pleasure.
And although we give each other shit and I'm like whatever,
I have nothing but love and respect for you.
And I hope that we can continue to do this for
however long you wanna do it.
'Cause it's been a beautiful, nourishing experience for me.
Ah, thanks man.
I would love to, I appreciate it, man.
I appreciate those kind words
and I feel the same way and the friendship is key.
Maybe I've learned that Adam needs his own show too.
We'll see.
Oh, but do this rapport that you think happened naturally,
you really think it happened naturally to you?
Yes, this is some Machiavellian.
Ah, I am a builder.
I'm a builder.
You're at home in the mirror practicing.
Have you ever seen "Taxi Driver?"
That's me.
Okay, I knew it all along.
You think that rapport natural to you?
If that was true,
I'd have to go home and really rethink my life.
I've built rapport on-
As somebody who considers myself a relatively okay
judge of character that would really rock me.
I've built rapport on the streets of Lagos, Nigeria.
I've built it.
I've seen you do your thing too
like when we were in Catalina,
and you were writing about (indistinct)
for the New York Times.
And I've seen the ease with which you just roll up on people
to try to get the story.
And for some reason, everybody just wants to talk to you.
You have a demeanor about you, like an affect,
that people are like, oh cool.
I wanna talk to this guy.
Nonthreatening.
Nonthreatening rapport builder.
Nonthreatening, yes.
(Adam laughing)
Another undervalued skill.
No, I appreciate it, man.
But I also think that, as you've learned,
since we talked about the podcast
and you're coming up on 10 years,
another thing that you learn is,
as a journalist and I'm sure you've learned this
in the seat you're sitting in right now,
people wanna tell their stories.
And so if you just open the channel,
they're gonna deliver it to you.
And I think that you're an early adopter
of the long form interview too,
which I think when you started,
even in the podcast realm,
they don't always go untapped for hours.
I mean, you and Joe Rogan,
and I can think of a couple of others,
but other people had more formatted shows
even the early adopters of podcasting.
And so I think that the fact that you go deep,
you're willing to listen that long and give people the space
to say whatever they have to say.
I mean, that's amazing.
So to be a part of this, I'm very grateful for it.
Grateful for your friendship, first and foremost.
I appreciate that.
Yeah, man.
Thanks for that question.
And you're long reads, long breath holds,
and going deep, back to free diving.
It all goes back to free diving.
Thanks Jonathan.
Your literary affectation for free diving.
Yes, I do have a...
Who knows?
I mean, I try not to think about
the kind of weird winding course of my career,
but who knows where it'll lead.
But it's been a fun ride.
All right, man.
Well, I think that concludes today's Roll On.
How do you feel?
I feel good.
I didn't even get to the hand drawn map of the moon.
That's right, you have this book sitting here.
Yeah, it's this map of, I went to the Hammer museum,
which they have the best gift shop ever.
And I found this 1940s, someone who was an astronomer,
looking at the moon through a telescope in the 40s,
drew these hand drawn topographic maps of the moon,
all their craters.
And I'm sure this was used
in planning for for the lunar exploration and all that.
Right, that's pretty cool.
Super cool.
I like how you're sharing a book
that no one else can get too.
Yeah, it's a book, it's called "Map of the Moon,"
by H. Percy Wilkins.
All right.
And we probably won't link that in the channels
because it's probably not in print.
No.
I think I'm supposed to give an approval to this
edge of the unknown story like right after we sign off.
So that should be up.
Cool, well, until we meet again, my friend, in two weeks,
as always super fun to chat with you.
And for anybody who's still listening,
a reminder if you wanna share your listener story with us,
leave us a voicemail at (805) 421-0057.
If you wanna enter to win tickets to the Anvil premier
in Los Angeles, send us an email at giveaway@richroll.com.
And we'll see you back here in two weeks.
Beautiful.
Peace.
Nice.
Namaste.
(upbeat drum music)